[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another one
of our live sessions here at
world science festival this of course is
some
hybrid of your daily equation that many
of you are familiar with also with
world science you the education platform
in which you can explore all sorts of
scientific subjects with world leading
experts and we're doing something a
little bit different
for today's live session normally as you
know i just kind of sit here
for an hour or two hours or sometimes
three hours and more and you know i
enjoy
just fielding your questions sometimes
throwing questions back
at you today we'll do some of that
but i'm also going to be joined today by
a guest
nobel laureate adam reese is here
who i'll bring in in just a few minutes
and we're gonna
discuss you know the things that led to
the breakthrough that he and his
colleagues achieved
back in 1998 and has rippled through our
understanding of physics ever since
so that's going to be an exciting
conversation and look as
as we just have a little preamble here
if you have particular questions
in cosmology having to do with issues of
einstein the cosmological constant the
expansion of space the accelerated
expansion of space
supernova explosions as standard candles
allowing us to determine cosmic
distances any questions in that arena
i'm going to give those priority when
adam is here so ask those and
you're more likely to get your question
addressed if it's in that domain but
again as always
feel free to bring up any questions at
all
spanning the gamut i'm happy to field
and we'll happy to address
any questions that come along so before
we get into the conversation just a
couple things
i always like it when you guys chime in
on
where you are tuning in from around the
world i like to see all the countries
scroll by it's kind of fun to see
where you all are from so do that and
i'll take a look at that
as well but i thought i'd spend a a
minute or two just on some
sciency news type things of
late some of you have asked me in fact a
number of you have sent me emails
or in twitter asked questions about the
xenon experiment that are searching for
dark matter has it found dark matter
and the answer is i don't have an answer
i don't think anyone
does at the moment or maybe some people
do and i'm in the dark
on this question of dark matter but
there's some anomalous data that has
come to light oh i'm really sharp today
on my metaphors and anti-metaphors
so this data has come to light about
dark matter that there
is an excess of certain kinds of
processes apparently happening that
don't agree
with the most pristine and economical
standard model of particle physics which
would suggest possibly additional
physics and that additional physics
might perhaps involve the dark matter so
it's really too early to tell
and look if you use history as your
guide
most of the almost breakthroughs
in physics turn out to not be
breakthroughs at all and that's the
nature of the beast
every so often you have some spectacular
insights such as the one we're going to
talk about with adam reese
but most of the time you think you have
some great breakthrough
and after you study it more fully and
after other teams of researchers
investigate it
you find that the result is actually
nothing unusual nothing unexpected at
all so of course
that is a very conservative perspective
my guess is that that is the case but
who knows
and if the experiment has detected dark
matter that will be one of the great
achievements of our age
so stay tuned on that another fun little
piece of physics news that i was i don't
know how i came upon it but
you guys know this this weird effect
that sometimes
hot water appears to freeze more
quickly than cooler water i mean it
seems completely counterintuitive
because for hot water to get to a
freezing temperature it has to
pass through every temperature in
between you would think and therefore
you would think
that hot water is going to take longer
to freeze because it has to
get to the lower temperature that the
other sample of water
already began with but remarkably
some people think that's not the case
and there's now some data supporting
that and i don't understand it fully
maybe adam does but the physics appears
to be the case that if your initial
sample is not
fully in thermal equilibrium name
there's not one unique temperature that
applies the entire sample
then different parts of the sample can
cool at different rates and
somehow can choreograph their cooling
in some unexpected way that finds
shortcuts to freezing so
it's kind of a interesting piece of you
know who would have thought that there's
still any question about
you know freezing of water right you
know so
those of you who think that physics is
done we're not even done with
understanding how water freezes so
there is a there is a long way to go
anyway so that's just a little bit of
sciency new stuff that's going on but as
i mentioned
we're going to begin in this first hour
with a conversation
with one of the faculty members who is
given a course in world science you
a course on cosmology and the expansion
of space
and that faculty member is adam reese
who i'm going to bring in now he's the
bloomberg distinguished professor and
thomas j
barber professor of physics and
astronomy at the krieger school of arts
and sciences at johns hopkins university
and he
is the co-recipient of the 2011
nobel prize in physics so
adam i think you are with us can you
hear me i am
great thank you for being with us this
this afternoon and
i don't know if you um are aware we
started this little series
when the pandemic hit just to
give people something in the afternoons
on well we were doing it every day for a
while but the live sessions were just
every friday
and we sort of have formed this little
community
of like-minded interested seekers from
countries from around the world who just
love to tune in and
chat about physics and science and
sometimes even
more philosophical things so the folks
who are watching will be asking some
questions in real time and i'll try to
pick some of those out as
you and i are talking about things but
um basically i just want to have a
little conversation about
cosmology and i thought i'd begin
though by just uh you know it's hard not
to
think about the things that we are all
facing at the moment how has the
pandemic been treating you are you home
are you in baltimore now or
yeah i'm in baltimore i'm at home you
know the one of the beautiful things
about working um
with space and observatories and in
particular the hubble space telescope
which is
what i mostly work with is you can do it
from anywhere you can do it from a
starbucks you can do it from
you know your home under uh under a
lockdown uh
in fact when all the observatories were
shutting down during
the initial outbreak you know somebody
has to go to the mountaintop
and put you know liquid nitrogen in the
doer hubble just keeps going and so uh
it was probably the least affected uh of
all that's sort of amazing
and and and i i should know this i
apologize but do you have kids
at home do i do um i have a nine year
old and a 16 year old so
you know going from teaching at johns
hopkins university back to
uh third grade uh math is uh
you know take some time take some
adjustment and take some study you have
to remember
that you let go of so so i'm just
wondering
at johns hopkins what is the disposition
of the administration are they putting
any
pressure on you guys to go back into the
classroom are they leaving it totally up
to you
yeah so you know up until a few weeks
ago there was the
optimism that uh we were gonna come back
in kind of a hybrid mode
but just yesterday uh they uh retrenched
that position and so everything's gonna
be online now
yeah yeah yeah i was thinking how you
know ahead of our time we were with the
world science festival when i
uh or uh school when i taught that uh
class you know because everything's
online
now exactly exactly you know it's funny
i was talking to a colleague a friend of
mine i don't know if you know
malik parrik at arizona state and he was
saying how
everybody he spoke to at the beginning
of the pandemic thought okay we're now
all going to be
isaac newton right newton retreated
during the black
death invent calculus and then calculus
figure out the universal law of gravity
we're going to come back to the world
with some sparkling new insights
in fact i feel quite bad about it
because the truth is i haven't done
anything that good
so exactly you know we were all given
our newton moment and uh
maybe some of us will come through with
it but anyway
let's just turn now i thought we jack
suggested if it's okay with you just
sort of
stroll through the history of
cosmological thought
going back to einstein really and then
leading up to the work that you and your
colleagues
so famously gave to the world so
obviously it was einstein who gave us
the general theory of relativity
back in 1915 he sits down the equations
and
i guess you could really say he was the
first person to use general relativity
in a cosmological setting but he kind of
came to
a conclusion that was at odds with what
we think about
the world today uh so i mean he did not
like the notion of an expanding universe
even those equations seem to suggest
that
many people say it was just a
philosophical prejudice is
is that what it was yeah you know i'm
gonna so
i'm gonna throw in here that right from
the beginning um
there was the tension between the theory
you know gravity it's beautiful general
relativity you could solve it
if you knew what circumstance you were
solving it in
and the observational component which is
where are we
you know what is are we in a
gravitational bound structure
well we are the milky way and then
what's beyond that
so um when einstein was first thinking
about the universe as a whole
astronomers were still sorting out uh
whether our galaxy the milky way was
everything uh or not um
and so at the time they told einstein
who asked you know are things expanding
contracting moving and
you know the response from astronomers
at the time was really to measure the
velocity of stars around us and say
you know nothing's really moving very
much i mean there's some random motions
but you know for the most part there's
no evidence of anything expanding or
contracting
again thinking perhaps the milky way was
everything
and so einstein struggled with how to
get
in general relativity a static universe
so it was more than
philosophy from so what you needed you
needed the right boundary conditions
and the initial ones from astronomers
were i would say not correct
and you know i always think einstein
gets a bad rap for making this blunder
about the cosmological constant
when he was really given i think you
know bad data
yeah so you mentioned the cosmology
constant of course einstein introduced
that
because his equations did not allow for
a static universe so he fiddles with the
equations
introduces this new term that does allow
for
a static universe i mean so just to give
a sense how how does this new term do
that
um how does this new term do that well
um you know the
the tendency for matter in the universe
is to be
attractive of course and pull things
together and so
any way you arrange the universe with
matter it's going to do that
some degree of that so how do you how do
you hold back
that tendency and you know einstein made
this amazing discovery
that really the gravity of empty space
itself could be
repulsive you know what he called the
cosmodrome constant and today
we would call more generally vacuum
energy the fact that
if you try to expand the universe and
every time you
do that you're going to put more vacuum
energy in the universe you're going to
have to do some work
in order to create that energy and the
way to think about that
really is it's like a universe inside a
cylinder
if you want to expand that cylinder and
create more energy in that cylinder
you're gonna have to do work therefore
it's gonna be hard for you to open that
cylinder pull that piston
and that's what we call negative
pressure it's the opposite of what you
think of as positive pressure when you
do work to compress it
and the weird thing is uh unlike
newton's theory of gravity
in einstein's theory of gravity negative
pressure
has the opposite sign of gravity and so
it is a direct consequence really of
that property having uh
new energy anytime you create more space
so did einstein
and and it's interesting to talk to you
about the stuff because
look i i lecture on this stuff all the
time and
sometimes i say things that i'm not
completely sure that i'm hitting the
historical progression with with
full accuracy and i guess nobody really
knows what was going on in einstein's
mind but i've never
found in einstein's writings that he
refers to repulsive gravity we all know
that the cosmological constant as you
note does gives rise to this
outward push as opposed to the usual
inward pull
of matter did einstein ever
think of it that way um so
i've done a fair bit of reading and i
would say i've never seen him refer to
it that way
but i have seen him later on in fact
there's a
famous i think almost paper that they
found in the archives in israel
where he refers for the first time to
the cosmodrome constant as
possibly due to energy in space and so
um you know that connection between this
mathematical term
and energy in space but you know in
terms of thinking of it as a repulsive
gravity it's really a term that shows up
in the friedman equation
that describes how space expands but i
think it
i think it's reasonable for people in a
basic way to think of it as
gravity going in the other direction
right right
and then and then i guess it was
would be a friedman who you mentioned
alexander friedman
george lemaitre as well in the early
years of the
1920s and so forth who alerted or at
least they thought they were alerting
einstein to this
idea that the bare general theory of
relativity did not allow for static
universe it's basically expanding or
contracting
but einstein tried to shut them both
down i mean he felt
really strongly i guess the quote for
lemaitre was your calculations are
correct but your physics is abominable
or something like that you know
right now now there's always been this
very long history
of physicists using more than
mathematics but a kind of idea of
elegance
um in order to bring intuition to a
problem and i think he thought
he had strong intuition but you know
again your intuition is only as good as
your observations of the world around
you and he
you know was limited in that way yeah i
mean
one suspects that most intuition is
built up
from experience and observation so like
you're saying if your observations
somehow have missed something vital
about the world
it stands to reason that your intuition
will be missing something vital too
but you know if einstein said to me that
that my physics was abominable you know
i have a feeling that i would have
like dissolved yeah right but but you
know
friedman who einstein actually said he
said your calculations
are wrong to friedman freeman just
stayed at it and ultimately convinced
einstein that the math was right and the
interpretation perhaps was wrong
uh lemaitre stayed at it too so i look
at these two figures as kind of
remarkable to stand up to einstein but i
guess
it was in 1929 when the observations
changed edwin hubble comes into the
story and
i guess and einstein famously visits
edwin hubble at the um california
observatories
and comes away gives his famous quote to
the media who were
sort of following him at the time oh
okay you know i'm convinced
the universe is expanding or this
interpretation and i think
you know i made a big mistake by
introducing this cosmological term which
he wrote to lemaitre
as well saying you know probably not
right
yeah there's also an interesting quote
there i think on that trip that you
mentioned
elsa went with him and as
the astronomers were showing einstein
around the observatory
elsa einstein got separated so she
started to talk to some of the folks
there and she said oh what do you what
do you guys do
and they said oh we like try to figure
out the nature of reality the nature of
the universe with this big machine big
telescope she goes oh
my husband he does that on the back of
an envelope
right that's right that's right so so in
1929
we learned that the distant galaxies are
all rushing away
as you say einstein kind of smacks
himself in the forehead
realizes that he could have predicted
this year before
but he didn't but at that time i would
think that
everybody came to the conclusion that
okay space is expanding but it's got to
be slowing
down right in its expansion right was
there anybody who was thinking
otherwise um you know uh
of course the consequence of this is
that it all
started at some point in time and of
course
uh there was another school of thought
sure it's expanding but i don't like
this
start this origin of the universe and so
fred hoyle and uh bondi and gold
developed the steady state idea of it
sort of just continuously expanding
forming new matter in between space but
not that it ever had to start
kind of like watching a river flow you
know it's always flowing but it doesn't
you know
have to start at a spot uh and uh
you know it was really not until the
1960s
that uh the heat left over from the big
bang was first
discovered and of course that's a direct
consequence
of the um idea of starting at a
singularity and then expanding not this
steady state continuously
expanding but forming new material to
keep it always looking fresh
so the notion of singularity is of
course a vital one and and the point
that you're making in terms of it hard
to square that with say
steady state cosmology just raise a
question that people ask
all the time and perhaps somebody will
ask it here too
we often think about the big bang is
like a little point
that then grows into the cosmos as we
know it but
if space is infinite at the moment then
that picture is
a little a little bit wrong right i mean
can you
expand i mean you know it's a it's a
tough concept to get intuition about but
you know our best understanding now is
that it's always
infinite even you know going back up
till that
point in time it's just bigger um you
know my dad used to love the joke you
know what's bigger than infinity
you know infinity plus one in a way
that's sort of what we're saying you
know the universe is
infinite and getting bigger right or at
the very least that the distances
between
finite distances between objects is
right it's always important to point out
there is a horizon
which is as far as we can see and you
know the rest is
you know reasonable extrapolation past
that so we have a a question from
purisha mishra who asked did the fabric
of
space exist before the big bang
thoughts on uh well i mean we don't know
i would say that
um you know our theory of what happens
uh in the universe really is a theory
that starts you know 10 to the minus 34
seconds or something after
this singularity and describes very
elegantly what happened after that point
it really i i don't know maybe you
have thoughts brian but um anything is
going to be much more theoretical about
what preceded that yeah absolutely i
mean the whole notion of before the big
bang
raises all sorts of conundra even
linguistic ones
is there is does the concept of before
apply
to this arena or are we extrapolating
the notion of before that applies to
more ordinary events in the universe to
an arena where it just doesn't apply or
was the big bang
an interesting event but not the actual
creation event of the universe maybe it
was just
an interesting event that took place in
a pre-existing universe in which case
the
the spatial fabric might have existed so
yeah these are these are
pretty tough questions but back to our
story right so
so so you know by the 60s 16
big bang is in steady state is out and
uh
and at that time just about everybody is
on board
with the idea that the expansion is real
yeah but because everything pulls on
everything else
it should be slowing down over time and
and so when did you start to
think i mean as a kid were you thinking
about
cosmology and i mean i was fascinated by
the stars i think i suffered the same
problem einstein did which is
as a kid i knew about the stars i didn't
really know about anything beyond
that i mean that i don't know you know
when you're a kid you know what you can
actually see with your eyes and i guess
maybe i wasn't well read enough but i
was pretty fascinated by just
uh the amazing distances and
time look back times two stars you know
my dad would tell me
you know a star you look at may be gone
now you know it's millions of light
years away so it may have
it may have died millions of years ago
and isn't there those were to me cosmic
ideas even though they were still within
our our galaxy
yeah hugely so i mean i just had that
conversation with my kids it turns out i
mean because normally we're
in new york city where a starry night
means there's two stars
in the sky but we're actually up in
upstate new york there's a helicopter
yeah right exactly like the helicopter
but now
we go out it's like starry night all the
time so it gives
opportunity and that is such a crazy
idea that you're looking at something
that may not be there any longer and
just it's
remnant light that it's shed thousands
or hundreds of thousands or millions or
billions of years ago
still in transit but of course this
turns out to be the very tool or trick
astronomers like me use to answer this
question because
if we look out we're looking back in
time when we measure a fact
about the universe as we infer it from a
distant object
we are inferring that fact about the
universe as it was in the past we're
inferring the past state of the universe
and so we can see
the universe expanding at a different
rate in the past and we can measure
how that rate has changed over time and
answer this question
you know is the expansion slowing down
and if so is it enough to stop the
expansion
which just turns the physics problem
around from was there enough matter
in the universe to cause that it's it's
you know very analogous to escape
velocity for a rocket
so your goal so if we jump even ahead
right now to the work that you did i
mean you went you're an undergraduate at
mit is that right and then uh
graduate student at at harvard and your
your advisor was kirsh bill christian
bill cress right yeah
yeah so press was my undergraduate bill
president undergraduate
advisor uh yeah years earlier
uh but uh so so you
set out to figure out if
the rate of cosmic slowdown was such
that you could say something about the
ultimate fate of
the cosmos was that the thinking that
was driving you
yes i mean you know to be very honest
right you're a graduate student your
postdoc your goal
is to survive get your phd you know to
write a paper to you know get a job but
you know the bigger glorious uh idea of
the projects
is okay astronomers had been measuring
for
years that there was not enough matter
to stop the expansion in the
the terms that we use omega omega matter
that represents the fraction of the
matter necessary to stop the expansion
and so
uh theorists told us it's probably going
to be
one that's almost a prediction of uh
our best theory of the big bang
inflation um
and yet when astronomers would go out
and try to count or or
quantify take a census of the universe
around us
they would end up with only about 30
percent of that total
and so in desperation i would say uh
cosmologists said look further out maybe
you know there isn't
uh that much matter right around us but
it's further out there it's sort of like
maybe we live in the boonies but you
know you haven't seen the cities
um look further out and so how do you
look further out
um and see the matter especially when
much of it might be dark
you know you may not even see it is to
actually
measure how much the expansion is
slowing down to essentially go directly
at the question
and uh in the late 1990s
it first became possible to use a kind
of exploding star called a supernova
type 1a to measure these distances in
red shifts and those are the two things
you really need to measure you need to
measure
distance and redshift that tells you how
fast the universe is expanding
and then you need to do that at a bunch
of different distances or redshifts to
get these slices in time
and measure how much the expansion was
slowing and so my
doctoral thesis was on improving the
precision of those
kinds of measurements just at the time
when
two teams of astronomers formed to find
more distant versions
of those explosions and make this
measurement and you were leading you you
were leading up one of those teams with
brian schmidt is that right
brian schmidt was leading it and i was
leading the analysis for our first
big set of data and at the time this
would have been
1997 you know we thought that the
expansion would be slowing down
uh it's captured in a quantity um we try
to measure called the deceleration
parameter it's the
second derivative of the scale factor of
the universe
and the sign tells you what that is and
the number itself tells you
relates very easily to how much mass is
in the universe
and so come late 1997 we had assembled
our first large set of distant
supernovae
to compare to nearby ones and this was
something that i was working on and you
know wrote a little computer program to
tell me okay
you know how much deceleration is there
and what is the implied mass of the
universe and
i kept getting a negative number for the
mass
which really meant that the deceleration
was acceleration and i hadn't even
noticed what was going on yet
and uh after staring at that and
thinking about that and you know going
back to you know the great
textbooks on this uh realized you know
matter can't do that it needs to be
something with the other sign and
enter again einstein's cosmos constant
and interestingly
we didn't mention this in the beginning
when einstein realized that this was a
possibility
and then it wasn't necessary in this
idea of physicists have liking
simplicity and elegance it became
oh well if it isn't dominant if isn't
necessary then it's zero
or probably zero or we don't understand
but let's
assume it's zero and i would say you
know it only
shown the light more brightly on this
problem that we had never really
understood that physics
and what that value should be and so we
were simply saying
the only physics we've ever heard of
that could cause what we're seeing
acceleration
is if einstein's cosmological constant
exists and it has a particular value
now are you jumping over a lot of hand
wringing in there because i mean look
every time that i've been fortunate
enough to get an unexpected result which
is only
which is rare like in a physicist's
career
yeah i think i made a mistake yeah and i
heard your beginning
your prologue here you're talking about
dark matter yes
non-experiment and it is true that you
know 98
of the time everything you hear about or
experience as a scientist
if it's exciting it's probably wrong but
now you
i almost want to jump in and say you
know we can't become too cynical about
that otherwise you exclude the
possibility
of discovering and i guess i was
fortunate that i was young enough to not
uh have enough of that experience so
yeah
did you have like you know literally or
poetically
you know sleepless nights because too in
the world
absolutely claim right the expansion is
speeding up instead of slowing down
going against decades of expectation
if you were wrong yes no one would
listen to you again right i mean
that that is true so brian and i really
sort of took the lead in checking the
numbers the calculations the
measurements and
you know we kept exchanging these kind
of amusing messages about
if this is wrong what are you gonna do
next you know and he liked wine so he
was gonna do a winery and i thought you
know
with my math skills maybe i could do
something on wall street because
we were both thinking we're pretty young
guys and you know this will be the thing
we're most famous for is getting this
wrong
sure you you definitely sweat that a
great deal
um but i think the key is to find
a middle ground between uh
being wrong or being wrong for an
interesting reason
and so what that really means is you
know you got to get the calculations
right you got to get the measurements
right because it's not interesting to
say oh i had a negative sign in my code
sorry everybody
but if it only looks like the universe
is accelerating if it's i'll call it an
apparent
acceleration and then somebody smart
person comes along and says you know why
it looks like this because
of some subtle effect that nobody's
written a paper about
or even something surprising in the
universe there is some kind of
intergalactic gray dust that nobody
has ever seen before then you go oh okay
i mean
you know this is as far as i can go is
is trying to get the measurements right
um and so you know you you find peace at
that level if you can
you can get to that point now there was
another team
that was absolutely undertaking led by
saul
from mutter right close contact was it
was it just yeah um you know they were
doing the same experiment
at the same time and of course you know
competition drives
uh a kind of um bringing together of the
timing of things if somebody's a header
behind they sort of scramble to not be
falling too far behind i mean
we're competing for telescope time and
so it so happened then that we really
sort of converged at this point in time
within months of each other
um not in direct communication but
you know nevertheless you know doing the
same experiment and
you know in early 1998 we started both
showing up
at conferences and going we're seeing
this and they were saying
we're seeing this and you know it became
very exciting
uh for the community in particular
because it sort of gets you past these
issues of
you know are you sure you don't have a
negative sign wrong or you know is there
some background
that you you know in your experiment is
being ignored
so for the most part it you know
accelerated no pun intended the
discovery itself so in 1998
you you both write the papers yeah
and look sometimes papers of that sort
generate a lot of backlash uh
a lot of uh people who just don't
believe it
right is that the case here was it
pretty much like
wow and acceptance right so i would say
there was a little bit of a limbo for a
couple of years i mean it certainly
caught people's attention uh you also
have to understand anytime somebody
makes
a claim of anything right we have so
much
established knowledge and measurements
that you know first
it has to fit it has to fit other things
too and so right away
people started pointing out you know
this actually makes
certain sense we were missing i was
about 0.7
of the universe in this critical okay we
thought it was in matter but maybe it's
an energy it still works for inflation
um you know there was a crisis an age
crisis where some of the oldest things
in the universe looked um to be
older than the universe itself this
fixed that so
first people check it against things
they know and say
is this already ruled out is this going
to make something worse and the quick
answer was actually
it makes some things better so we
survived i would say those first couple
of years simply because of that
and then of course by the early 2000s
observations of the cosmic microwave
background
the anisotropies were actually used to
independently measure the energy density
of the universe and came to the same
conclusions
yeah in case you're just joining us
first i want to apologize for my dog
that's barking in the background i can't
i can't turn her off i wish i could at
the moment
but we're talking to nobel prize winner
adam reese from johns hopkins university
about this wondrous discovery
that the expansion of space is speeding
up not slowing down that it's
accelerating so
so so so people began to warm to this
idea as you're saying
but as a theorist right i have to say
that this this sent us into a bit of a
tail spin
at at first because for many reasons
actually it made it
at first it seemed like it was difficult
to square with certain of the
beyond the standard model ideas that
we've been developing for a very long
time but then people found ways to do
that
but the number the actual amount of this
cosmological
constant or call it dark energy this
source of anti-gravity that's pushing
things outward instead of pulling things
inward
sure it is say 70 percent of the mass
energy budget of the universe but when
you put that
into other units the units that perhaps
are more
familiar to the folks who study particle
physics
the number is utterly bizarre
right i mean in those units it's 10 to
the minus 120 10 to the minus 122 or so
you know a decimal point with a string
of zeros
and then like a one at the end of it
so so to us that's just
an incredible challenge to ever explain
that number is that something that how
do you look at that do you look at that
as a as a problem of the way the
theorists are
are modeling how the universe works or
is this a real fundamental issue
in how humans will ever understand the
deep structure of reality
right you know it's funny i uh always
thought of this as a pre-existing
problem that had been swept
under the rug and that by making this
observation
we only lifted up the rug again um
we it didn't make the challenge
any worse that sword was cast in the
stone before and i go back to
stephen weinberg who had written a paper
a number of years earlier saying
geez if the cosmogenical constant uh had
the
natural value none of us would be here
you know would have
caused space to accelerate with such
great you know gusto that gravitational
structures never would have formed and
so
that can't be close to right i i have to
imagine
that you know there's some kind of
anathropic
argument or you know maybe there'll be
deep physics that sets the value
but um you know he in some ways almost
predicted the value that we have
because that it's got to be compatible
with life
yeah yeah yeah i want to so so
there were theorists who are on the
books at least as suggesting this
possibility but i want to go back
to the actual approach that you took to
get to this discovery you
have this wonderful little visual that
i'm going to bring up now
and you know say a few words if you like
and then i have a couple
questions on it so yeah i think i'll get
out of the way
yeah there we go that's space it's
expanding and there's supernovae going
off in those galaxies
and uh you know if we watch some
galaxies we're gonna find one and we're
gonna
measure that light and that light is
getting red-shifted it's getting
stretched by the expansion of space
um with that graphic also you can
imagine that light is heading out in all
directions and so the further away we
are the smaller slice of that light we
get
so it also is fainter and so
as observers we would like to measure
the property that you see there which is
that grid size that's what we call the
scale factor the size of that grid how
that grid changes over time
and because there is no grid we have
found in space
uh instead of measuring the grid size we
measure that wavelength of light that
you see there we measure how stretched
it is
um and instead of measuring how far away
the other objects are
uh well sorry we do measure how far away
they are instead of measuring time
how far back in time or how long it's
taken the light
uh to reach us um and so this is how we
we map the expansion rate of the
universe so
there's so many moving parts in a way to
to get to the result yes that that
like you said you and and and brian
schmidt
and and the other team led by saul
promoter
just i assume you know possibility by
possibility of
just ruling out any more prosaic
explanation
but i still see papers yes i'm just
wondering what you i still see papers
even recently coming out which like
it's not correct i challenge them so so
is it
obviously i'm assuming there's nothing
to them but but what what
what are the criticisms that at least
people posit and what were they doing
wrong
so so you should know first of all that
you know we have now about
i would say five or seven depending on
how you count it five to seven
independent routes so the route we used
was to look at exploding stars
and see the acceleration but completely
different ways of mapping or measuring
the universe measuring other features
other ways of measuring distance other
physics of the universe so we have you
know the five to seven ways makes us
very confident
um and so uh the most common phenomenon
when somebody says oh this is wrong is
they're starting out their argument by
throwing out
five or six of the seven ways
and they only address one of them and of
course this is the challenge in sciences
you know cosmology is hard we do need
multiple ways we weren't confident or
sure
that the universe was accelerating until
we had these
multiple techniques so i think it's you
know it's always unreasonable to discard
data um if you don't have
some really strong rationale and then of
course as you said
it's very challenging to explain the
cosmological constant and so
there's always the the willingness i
would say to say okay let's say we throw
out
six flavors of data that show this and
what if we
uh imagine some
like i said some gray dust in the
universe that makes distant objects look
dimmer
what if we analyze the data in a
different way one can often play games
with sort of statistics
and then you know they may reach a
conclusion in in
a recent case where you know the
universe isn't
so different in terms of its expansion
history as a universe without any matter
or without any cosmodrome constant and
you know maybe that's only
you know three standard deviations away
from the best fit and somehow
through a series of uh translating
errors i would almost say to media
it becomes maybe the universe is not
accelerating
okay okay yeah yeah but i mean the
result stands
is the bottom line and it's one that we
have to deal with now
key to the observations that you're
describing of course is light
traveling from say the supernova through
expanding space to our telescopes
and one of the folks who's watching us
right now
who describes their name as egg
leaves i'm not exactly sure i presume
that's not their real name
asks the question but what if the speed
of light has not always been the same
is that something that could affect the
results it
it could it i would probably say it
would
you know it's an assumption we make
right from the beginning and we do make
a number of assumptions
i should point out in cosmology we
almost always start with a few
assumptions like
we don't live in a special place um we
don't live in a special time
and so these assumptions which are often
wrapped up
into a fancy name the cosmological
principle
um sort of allow us to do physics they
allow us to make measurements and
interpret them
because if you said every domain could
have completely different physics in in
the universe
you know you would only be able to look
out at the stars and the galaxies and
say isn't that a pretty show
you wouldn't be able to actually try to
turn it into hard measurements now
having said that
we start out with that on zots that you
know physics is not different in other
places in the universe
and then we analyze the data in that
context and it fits
these model lines beautifully i mean
it's not like our measurement is one
object you know we have supernova after
supernova at different redshifts all
fitting the predicted now accelerating
line and so we say you know it seems so
so it it doesn't look like the speed of
light is changing uh
over time everything seems to agree very
well if we found
uh anomalous results and i guess i would
even say outside the cosmological
constant you know we'd have to struggle
again and say
you know could there be something else
could the speed of light change with
time
right and and you know every result
every observational result at some level
is
is theory dependent because you've got
to place your observations within some
theoretical structure
there's been i don't know what the right
word is kerfuffle argument
so you mentioned inflationary cosmology
and and many do look at it inflationary
cosmology as
the best approach that we have to
understanding
physics from just after the big bang or
depending on how you define the big bang
maybe including the big bang
through the accelerated expansion that
that you guys found
but there are some who think that we're
jumping the gun and committing
to this inflationary theory which uses
the very same physics that you're
talking about right you know repulsive
gravity of a much
higher magnitude in the earliest
fraction of a second
giving rise to the outward swelling then
things do slow down for a while and then
they pick it up again as the dark energy
that you and your colleagues discovered
causes the expansion space to accelerate
what's your view of inflation is it i
mean
do you do you question it or is it you
know it's it's an i think it's a
powerful framework you know
it relies on physics that we already
know
in terms of general relativity and the
idea of vacuum energy
it solves an observational problem we
didn't understand any other way
how you know you can solve the the
flatness problem how space can be so
flat how you can
solve the horizon problem how uh
opposite ends of the sky
uh seem to be in equilibrium even though
they've never been in contact
um and uh it may not be a unique answer
it may not be the only way to address
that
but you know it is powerful and um
and it's it's it's a useful model but
you know the expression you know
uh you know not all models are right but
some are useful
uh you know it i think it fits that
right
and you know another thing that comes
out of the inflationary
paradigm and it's quite relevant to
the dark energy that we've been talking
about is one explanation for the value
of the dark energy
could be that we live in a multiverse
that there are many distinct universes
each has say a different value of the
dark energy
you have enough of these universes in
fact i got a little visual i kind of
make use of our technology oh yeah there
they are
each of these guys here is its own
universe each with a different value of
the cosmological constant
then the fact that we have this weird
value would just be
uh you know an artifact of where we
happen to be and as you noted it's
life right imagine you you know you
encountered
some you know crude physicists on
another planet some distance from their
sun trying to derive from first
principles the
separation of their planet from their
sun
and and you'd step in and say hey i have
news for you you know there are many
planets and many stars and
you know this is just a random
environmental parameter but it had to
work out for you
had to be not too close not too far and
uh so you know will are we in that same
situation or not
yeah i mean so copernicus right spent a
long time trying to calculate 93
million miles earth's on distance and as
you're saying now we'd be like hey
copernicus you're a real smart guy
but there isn't a first principles
calculation of a number that's a
historical artifact that
is compatible with us being here but
beyond that probably has no fundamental
significance
so let me ask you this question then
because i think this is more up your
alley
um i'm comfortable with an anthropic
argument like that when we talk about
you know something like uh why we're at
such a great distance from our sun you
know because
i'm able to see other planets around
other stars
and i get oh there's a distribution
there were lots of options
when we talk about the multiverse you
know we really talk
about options that i'm not sure
or distributions i'm not sure that you
know we can claim
either exist you know that we know they
exist it seems like there
are um prerequisites to making an
anthropic argument
and i wonder have we checked those boxes
yet yeah i
i think that's the big question and it's
an argument that
well i mean i've been having a an
ongoing conversation with paul
steinhardt
for years now and and paul as you know
and i'll just remind the folks that are
watching us he's one of the architects
of the inflationary theory
with alan guth and andre linde and
andreas albrecht and so on so you know
he has skin in the game for the
inflationary theory and yet
for the very reasons that you're saying
adam the fact that
okay if this theory gives rise to many
universes
then if you're going to be able to say
anything concrete about its predictions
you need to know
the demographics of those universes you
need to know their probabilistic
description of the kinds of qualities
that these
universes have and and so paul whenever
i talk to him about this he says
absolutely you need that and that he
says in his view
is such a new quality of the theory that
doesn't come out of the mathematics that
was developed into the 1980s and 1990s
he says that's no longer the
inflationary theory
that's that's a wishful theory that
doesn't yet exist
right and so whereas many folks like me
who sort of view this distribution of
universes as an add-on that we need to
tack on to the inflationary theory
he says don't think about it that way
it's too big a thing to tack on
it is the theory at some deep level
right and that's why he has been
developing
alternate ideas that don't require
emotion
and you know i would almost say it in a
more simplistic way you know i would say
to my theoretical brethren and
and sisters um you know don't be
satisfied with our cosmological constant
as um uh a consequence
of a multiverse anthropologically set
because
you know we haven't yet demonstrated
those distributions and those
demographics
and we could miss something important
just by
waving our hands and saying well that's
how it comes to be i mean
you know in the same way almost that
people would have waved their hands
you know in the 1950s and 60s and said i
guess the cosmological constant is zero
because we don't see any evidence of it
you know it's
similar sort of of story you know you
don't actually have
all the information yet to make connect
rigorously connect those dots
and uh you know we could lose out on
this clue by
doing that prematurely yeah yeah without
a doubt
and and you know some people view the
cosmological constant
as this uh very painful
development in physics some view it as
the greatest opportunity
that that theorists have ever had and i
should know the answer to this question
but i
but i don't actually so let me ask you
in your paper
do you mention cosmological constant or
dark energy or do you just stick to the
observation
the title of our paper is observational
evidence for an accelerating universe
and a cosmological conflict constantly
so that's interesting to me because
when i think back to the papers
on the microwave background radiation
the observational paper of penzias and
wilson famously
excess radio tempe excess uh antenna
temperature
excess tenon there's no cosmology no
expanding universe and so forth because
i guess their view was
you know we don't want to commit to
anything like that the observations of
the observations they
are unassailable but the interpretation
might change over time
did you worry about including say
cosmological constant
so bold faced and i forgot that it was
right in the title
did you worry about that because nothing
will obscure the validity of your
observations but cosmological constant
may be an idea that goes away
right and i think the answer is you know
in a way we had the benefit of our
ignorance as
observers you know even you know at that
point in time
we did not we were not aware that one
could generalize the idea of a
cosmological constant
to dark energy it doesn't have to have a
specific equation of state
uh as though that energy is static it
could be the result of a field and
uh that field could be changing and so
you know there is a broader range of
possibilities and i think at the time
that was the only physics you know we
were aware of and we wanted to
desperately
fit the data you know we had the data
and we wanted to fit lines through it
and that was you know the only piece of
physics we knew and so you know i think
we put it in and
amazingly to this day it is still the
best fit to the data
even as we open up the possibility the
range to dark energy with all kinds of
different what we call equations of
state
um the best fit is still within you know
a few percent
of minus one the famous you know value
for the cosmological constant
so i hope you don't mind me asking feel
free to move on if you don't want to go
here at all but
so you're lying in bed you're asleep
the phone rings it's early morning
and it's the nobel prize committee what
in the world was that
like it's bananas i mean it's you know
as
as a scientist right i mean we're we're
not
wired for or expecting any kind of
experience
like that we're not celebrities you know
i'm uh
you know grunt through the data figure
out what's going on
making measurements and so it's it's a
complete
shock i mean to your system um
i mean it's exciting but it's uh and
it's you know i mean
you're certainly gratified that the work
is being recognized and that your
colleagues are being recognized with you
and so there's
that tremendous excitement but it's like
a bolt of lightning
so i think it's the case that both you
and einstein
got the nobel prize at the same age i
think you're both
42 if i'm not mistaken i was 41 actually
41.
even you peter i know einstein so he's
einstein
you know what one of the first things
you have to realize about the nobel
prize is it's not for being the smartest
person you know it is
you know for making a discovery which
you know people can make by being lucky
or
you know maybe a little dogged um so
yeah did it affect your um
motivation i mean in some sense you sort
of hit the highest
accolade now we all know that it's not
about the accolades per se but look
we're all human
when you reach the pinnacle in that way
did it affect your motivation in any way
you know i uh i knew at that time that i
really liked doing science and i really
you know it you know hours are lost you
know the clock spins
by you know i'm not i'm you know my job
is not a job
and so i didn't really want to change
that and
you know being 41 it was way too early
to think about stepping away
from the thing that i really enjoyed the
most and so
um i decided i was going to keep doing
research pretty much the same way
and and i have uh you know i continue
to use the hubble space telescope you
know what i've been working on more
recently
is very precise measurements of what we
call the hubble constant the rate at
which the universe expands
and also interestingly in the last few
years we've seen that
those values measured in the we call the
late universe around us now
do not seem to agree with the predicted
values based on the causing microwave
background
in conjunction with our standard model
now of the universe which includes
the cosmological constant um we are
still off
by you know about nine percent which may
not sound like a lot but
in the last decade we've improved the
precision of the measurements by about
an order of magnitude
and so that nine percent has become plus
or minus two percent
and so you know it's again looking like
something isn't quite fitting and you
know maybe there'll be another wrinkle
yeah so people have have kicked around
measurements and discrepancies in
the in the holocaust for a very long
time right
do you think we're finally settling down
is that yeah
these this right this period is much
more interesting in my mind
because you know decades ago uh people
might debate the value of the hubble
constant when they were measuring it in
exactly the same way
so there wasn't really a possibility
that it was interesting physics
uh it was really you know the challenges
of systematic uncertainties but
in the last 10 years uh i think we've
been able to
attack systematics in a much more
methodical
way um and we have much more precise
observatories like the
the planck observatory the hubble space
telescope
the european space agency gaia mission
which measures parallaxes that is used
to calibrate
uh ultimately these distance ladders and
um now what we're seeing are
discrepancies
not based on who is measuring it or what
technique but
what epic in the universe they are
measuring it from are they measuring it
from the beginning or from the end and
that
smells to many people like something in
the story
that we used to connect the beginning to
the end yeah right
so so what what value is it settling
down
say today too yeah so it so it turns out
if you measure it
starting at the beginning of the
universe you predict the value should be
about
67 plus or minus 0.5
and if you measure quickly tell people
the units and what that's doing
that's uh in units of kilometers per
second per megaparsec which is a
it's actually units of inverse time or
you could think of it as it's in units
of a rate of expansion meaning how much
time before the universe doubles again
so if i
turned it into units of doubling again
it would be about
uh 10 billion years before it doubles
again
in the present universe but we use these
more
units that are closer to the actual
measurement so the
the people who measure the early
universe predict it should be
67 plus or minus a half and people who
measure in the late universe
get something more like the low 70s like
73
is a pretty typical number and the
uncertainties are coming down to about
one and a half we're hoping to reach one
percent later this year
and uh so the tension we call it has
risen to about five
sigma five standard deviations um and
appears to be fairly robust because uh
we look at different ways of measuring
in the late universe or different ways
in measuring the early universe
and they agree with each other but don't
agree across this
time divide right
and and so that again is a fruitful
place no doubt for uh
someone to uh sort out that that
interesting story
so adam it's been great talking to you i
have two final questions before i let
you get back to
real work uh one is as i mentioned at
the outset
this uh series emerged during the
pandemic
we called it your daily equation and
what i would do is i would sort of pick
an equation each day
explain it in everyday language and try
to illustrate it and so on
so in that spirit do you have a favorite
equation
yes it's i mean it would have to be the
friedman equation which is
the uh equation it's a solution to
einstein's general relativity
as applied to the universe on the
left-hand side
of the equation is the kinematic
description of the universe it's
how the scale factor a that movie that
you saw
it's that uh it's a differential
equation it just simply says
this is how the universe expands on the
right hand side
are the sources or uh of uh
the exchanging expansion of the universe
the matter density
the dark energy any physics that causes
it's almost like the f equals m a really
for
the universe where you know we try to uh
measure the a
and learn about the f and the m yeah so
for those of you
uh who have been following your daily
equation there is an episode i can't
tell you which number it is where i
describe the fremont equation so
you can actually go back and see the
mathematical details but what i will say
is
that friedman is the same freedman that
adam and i were talking about
at the beginning of the conversation who
einstein didn't believe
when he put forward these possibilities
of a non-static
universe so he gets his due right he's
like
this equation is named after him and
it's one that's useful
and used in understanding the
cosmological history
final question comes from one of our
viewers who calls him or herself or
their self
i should say quantum maths and says i'm
about to enter high school
and i'm really interested in physics and
mathematics especially theoretical
physics
what would you suggest for me to pursue
this interest
right uh that's a great question um you
know
i always think that at that stage
um if you're interested in that you know
you want to take all the
physics and mathematics that's available
in your school
um and rather than quote try
to get engaged in you know the very
advanced research which can be very
off-putting because it can be very
difficult
is to pick up popular books i'll say you
know books by brian greene and other
people
that tell you about the current state of
play
where the questions are because those
things are
inspiring um without
sort of ruining it for you in a way
before you have really the tools to
actually
get involved in that work so you develop
the tools but keep your inspirations
in your forefront by you know reading
the sort of late person or interested
person uh books and you know
documentaries and
online courses uh again meant more for
lay people
yeah no i fully agree and i'm not saying
that so someone goes out and buys my
book so thank you for mentioning it but
you know you got to learn the basics but
you kind of hunger for what's happening
at the frontier and there's just so much
out there today you know when i was a
kid there just wasn't all that much and
it's an exciting thing that there
is so much online material now for kids
to keep their
their excitement going including world
science you so i'll give it a plug you
know adam gave a wonderful
master class in world science you where
you can go and and hear about
the things that we spoke about today you
know in greater detail directly from
from adam and there are all sorts of
other classes at world science hue from
string theory
some in philosophy of consciousness
those very broads of things
i i recommend to the young
and the mature to go check that out it's
an interesting thing to do
so adam again thank you so much for
joining us
today thank you for the world science
you master class
and um and good luck in nailing down
the the hubble parameters so we we want
to know how quickly
space is expanding all right good luck
and thanks a lot
all right thank you thank you so for
everybody else i'm gonna
carry on with our more traditional way
of doing these live sessions by just
turning
right to some of your questions
and uh let's see so i saw one that
streamed by
that was on uh tachyons uh where is oh
yeah steve
bermeo uh oh but maybe he's talking
about
the jello photo kizmelakas question i
can't know
but uh having to do with tachyons and
whether tachyons can be so there it is
right can we use taco to time travel to
the past
is what is asked there and as steve
bermeo begins to answer
tachyons are indeed hypothetical
particles that's correct
completely correct steve and uh the
question is
could you use them for backward time
travel well again time travel to the
past is a
very thorny issue in physics we
full well understand how to time travel
to the future that's not mysterious
it's a technological hurdle to achieve
but as we've discussed in these
sessions before there are many ways to
do it you can travel out into space near
the speed of light you come back
near the speed of light your clock
relative to a clock on planet earth will
have ticked off far less time
so when you step out of your ship you
may be a year older but everybody around
you could be five years older or a
billion years older all depending on how
close to the speed of light and how long
your journey was so that is time travel
to the future
the past is much much more difficult and
we don't know if you can do it most
i think physicists would suspect that we
can't but here's the thing with tachyons
the weird thing about tack outs these
hypothetical
faster than light particles if i have a
say a tachyon gun
and i say fire it from one hand to
the other from my right hand to my left
hand and a tachyon in
my frame of reference my perspective is
traveling from the tachyon gun
and hitting my hand if you're traveling
in a spaceship
in a particular direction of particular
speed
your interpretation of the scenario will
be completely different from your
perspective
you will conclude that the tachyon hit
my hand before i pulled the trigger
that the tachium will hit my hand before
i pulled the trigger so
it isn't actually time travel to the
past but it's
an inversion of causality it's something
that normally we would think about as
happening in the future the tachyon
hitting my hand
you will say that that took place prior
to the event that normally we would say
happened earlier
namely my pulling the trigger
tachyon hits my hand before i pull the
trigger from your perspective
so that's the notion of
the weirdness of time that emerges
if tachyons are real that
cause and effect can be interchanged now
again as steve pointed out we do not
think that tachyons are real but as a
hypothetical exercise in understanding
the properties of relativity it's an
interesting exercise
but who knows whether these particles
are real many think that they
are not road runner relevant to the
conversation that i just had with adam
isn't the cmb everywhere and therefore
everything is relative
to it yeah in a sense the answer to that
is yes
so when we talk about the cosmic
microwave background radiation we're
talking about radiation
that means heat light is entering our
telescopes or if you allow me to be
more poetic it's entering our eyes we
can't literally see it with our eyes but
just imagine that we could
and that might lead you to think that
there's something special about where i
am because the heat is now
hitting my eyeball right here from the
big bang
but regardless of where i am in the
cosmos
the idea is that the heat would be there
because
this heat fills all of space so imagine
that the early universe
it is a ball filled with photons filled
with heat and as it expands
the photons are traveling this way and
that
but they continue to fill the space so
regardless of where your eyeball is
there is a photon from the big bang that
is there ready to
enter your eye so there's nothing
special about where i am there's nothing
special
about the cosmic microwave background
radiation
that i my eyeball or my telescope
receives
there is something quite special though
about a particular
frame of reference with respect to which
the heat left over from the big bang
will appear uniform it'll appear
homogeneous because if you are moving
relative to that cosmological frame of
reference
then the photons will be redshifted
they'll be blue shifted depending upon
how you are moving
and you will not have that homogeneity
and indeed planet earth is moving
relative to that cosmological frame of
reference so when adam
was referring to the cosmic microwave
background radiation and its
properties what we often do is when we
analyze the heat
left over from the big bang we subtract
out the motion of planet earth namely we
do some data analysis on the
measurements of the microwave background
radiation to figure out what it would
have looked like
if we were not looking at it from
a planet that is orbiting a star that
itself
is orbiting the center of the milky way
galaxy
so we do this processing of the data to
figure out what it would look like from
that
uniform cosmological frame of
reference so in that sense everything is
relative to the cosmo
cosmic microwave background radiation as
it sets the frame of reference
relative which relative to which
that radiation appears uniform
roadrunner asks why does our frame of
reference matter well our frame of
reference matters because
our goal our goal is physicists and and
adam's goal we just heard from him is
not to
merely come to some understanding
of what the universe looks like from
planet earth that's interesting
but however much we love our planet
there's something else that we
physicists love even more
and that is the true nature of reality
so we don't want to be biased
by the observations that happen to be
available to us and the features that
they happen to have
as we walk around earth we want to
figure out qualities
of the universe that would be true
anywhere and any when and
that is what forces us to understand
what reference frame we are actually in
relative to say the microwave background
radiation
subtract out the bias which that
particular
motion through space results in
and thereby conclude what
the microwave background radiation looks
like to any observer anywhere
who is not moving relative to this
cosmological
reference frame and that allows us
to pinpoint qualities of reality
as opposed to qualities of how reality
happens to look from planet earth that's
the difference and that's why it matters
okay so what else do we have here
anything else on cosmology or
quantum mechanics um so um
srinivas krishna asked did the big bang
start
one universe or the entire multiverse
and and you know i can't help but bring
up my fun little multiverse video i'm
gonna
have more i don't have very many
interesting visuals
today but look if each one
of those spheres represents
a universe okay that means that each one
of those
spheres has its own big bang if you will
now how did it all get started from the
get-go nobody knows
but when we talk about big bang in the
context of what you're seeing behind me
in the context of a multiverse we're
really talking about
multi-big bangs each universe has its
own big bang giving rise to its own
expanding
portion of space but the different
universes have distinct
big bangs and therefore the big bang did
not start off the whole thing
rather the big bang is the name that we
give to the process
that yields our expanding universe that
is the
difference between them and that's the
language that we
typically use so
let's see
so um shuvik mandal asks
hello sir which latest research and
physics do you think
could bring a revolution in science like
the revolutions associated with
relativity and quantum mechanics
and i i don't know i don't know
obviously if i knew the answer to that
question i would quickly leave
this live discussion and get to work on
that particular idea
and yeah that's the big question that we
all ask like we live these finite lives
with a limited amount of time
and when you start on a research project
you could be embarking on something that
takes
months to years and when you don't have
that many
years left you want to choose carefully
you know when i was a young
graduate student i i really in some
sense didn't care what i worked on i
mean the
area i wanted to work in cosmology and
quantum mechanics but
if there was an interesting sounding
problem i'd be like yeah okay i'm in
let's go and i'd work on it because at a
young stage
you have all these years of research
ahead of you
and you just want to get in the game and
i think that's the way young researchers
should
approach the research projects that are
available to them
but as you get older you start to ask
the question that
shuvik asks which is
which of those research projects really
has the potential to be revolutionary
right if you're already in the game then
the next stage is hopefully to work on
something that will be utterly
revolutionary and and
obviously no one knows the answer to
these questions you only have post-facto
analyses and you're like oh okay that
was the idea that led to the revolution
i mean look at adam reese
when he started to work on the
measurements
of cosmological expansion he
and his colleagues were set on
determining the rate of
slowdown of the expansion of space the
rate of slowdown
of the expansion of space and that would
have been an interesting result to find
but i don't think had it turned out that
it really was slowing down i don't think
it would have
been revolutionary i i don't think
i could be wrong but i should have asked
him but uh but i suspect that
that result would not have been awarded
the nobel prize
unexpectedly working on a project that
was important but perhaps not
revolutionary
a revolution ensued because the result
was not what anyone
expected rather than slowing down and
speeding up
so it's just to say that it's very hard
to to answer that question but
my gut feeling shivok mandal
is that the next revolution will come in
fully understanding what
space is right we know a lot about space
we know a lot about time we know that
space is expanding
we know that time has these interesting
qualities some of which i addressed in
the first question about
time travel but we still are at a loss
to
fully articulate what space is and what
time
is are they made of ingredients finer
gradient ingredients is that the way we
should think about the nature of the
fabric of space and time
is fabric the right word is space
actually stitched together by
threads like a piece of fabric is and if
so what are those threads are those
threads the
threads of quantum entanglement are
those threads the strings of string
theory
i don't know but i suspect that
answering those questions
is where the next revolution in physics
is likely to come from that that is my
guess
all right let me head back to the
question so viraj
kapani is a new book coming from me well
i'm there are new books not not from me
i'm not
at the moment working on a new book you
know my last book
thankfully is not that old yet it came
out in february
and the paperback has not even been
released yet
trying to figure out when to release the
paperback in this strange
pandemic world part of me wants to hold
the paperback
in reserve for when the world is a
little bit more normal and you can go
out and
talk to people about your ideas and have
events and things of that sort but
but we'll see but that that's really uh
the next book if you will it's the
paperback of the old book
i'm also working starting to work on
some
things that may not be interested
interesting i should say to this
audience
in fact i'd be interested if you have
any thoughts on it
but i'm you know i wrote a fiction book
for kids
a very short book years ago icarus at
the edge of time it was called about a
boy going to a black hole
and einstein's general theory of
relativity does kick in and dictates how
the narrative unfolds so there is
an intersection with the kinds of ideas
that we typically talk about here
but i was thinking of flushing that out
into a very short
more of a parable i'm thinking of
fleshing it down to a full-fledged
full-fledged book that you know for kids
sort of
but also for adults that are just
interested in in
odysseys that have a scientific
through line so that may be the next
thing that i
work on very different from the kinds of
things that i've done before
i'm just wondering anybody would anybody
read that so if you would
put in the comments give me some
encouragement if that's a
direction that that i might go um
so at
ram three letch asks mr green i'm
extremely confused about the prominence
of the intuition that smaller particles
make up larger structures in physics do
you think
leaving it could offer any hope and i
i'm not sure what the confusion
is age ram adrian iii letch because to
me it's so
intuitive but maybe it's just because i
have been
living within the reductionist
perspective
all of my professional life and even
before
i became a professional physicist the
notion that
things are made of smaller things
is so central to the way we have
organized our understanding of reality
and it has been so
powerful right if you were to ask and i
think it was
richard feynman who was asked this
question he was asked
if we were to leave one sentence summary
of the most
important thing that science has ever
discovered
let's say we were given one it's sort of
like a twitter for the future
right we were given like 280 characters
that would be delivered
to the future or maybe delivered to a
civilization that replaces us after we
destroy ourselves and want some
record of the most important thing that
we have
ever discovered what would that be and
richard feynman said
that though that matter is made of atoms
that the world is made of atoms so the
atomic hypothesis
that all of the structure all the stuff
in the world around
us is nothing but a collection of atoms
that we can see in the periodic table
arranged in different configurations the
fact that all the richness of the world
right from
from tables and chairs and trees and
grass and clouds and
mountains and dogs and people and and
ponds and water
all that stuff that all that stuff
is nothing but atoms and a small
collection
of atoms brought together into different
configurations he said that
is the most important thing that we've
discovered and
and we have of course carried on with
that very reductionist perspective
that the atomic hypothesis articulates
because
we now know that each atom is nothing
but
a collection of smaller particles
protons and neutrons and electrons
arranged in certain patterns
and we also know that neutrons and
protons are also made of smaller
particles
quarks arranged in particular
combinations and particular patterns
and so that idea that reality is
constructed
from finer and finer ingredients brought
together in
ever more complex and interesting
patterns
when articulated not just in the english
language but through the power of
mathematics has allowed us to understand
so much about the world so at dram three
lech when you say do you think
leaving that perspective could offer any
hope
i don't i don't think so and by that i
don't mean
that there shouldn't be other ideas
because the reductionist perspective
needs to be married together with
synthesis not only do you want to know
the fundamental ingredients you need to
truly understand the rules by which they
come together
and hopefully understand even complex
configurations
of those particles that come together in
a living system and a brain
things that we've not yet been able to
figure out so if you marry the
reductionist perspective with this
perspective of synthesis then to me that
is the most powerful framework for
making
progress are there other ideas that
might supersede these
of course there might be but if you ask
me
i am quite confident that for a very
long time if not forever
that this will be the way that we think
about reality
all right um
rob vandenberg asks if you were a
betting man what would you put
money on time is
a partial or not i'm not exactly sure
about the second half of the sentence
i don't understand the first half but
perhaps what you mean that
time is emergent as opposed to
fundamental
maybe that is what that language means
and let me know
rob if i'm misinterpreting your question
and
if i was a betting man i'm not a betting
man i'm very conservative in those
regards i don't understand why people
bet i don't understand people
going to casinos where if you stay long
enough you will
lose why is that fun if you stay long
enough
you will lose
the odds are skewed in the favor of the
house
why is it fun to play a game that's
rigged
anyway that's a separate question so let
me take the betting person out of the
story and just sort of
adjust the second half i do suspect the
time is emergent
i do suspect that time ultimately will
be viewed as
not a fundamental quantity or concept
within our understanding of natural law
but rather will be viewed as something
that emerges for something finer
and what that finer thing is at the
moment we don't know
but if that is a correct interpretation
of your
question rob then if i were a betting
man i would bet on time
being emergent so lisa asks me
what my favorite equation is
i asked adam what his favorite equation
is
and i guess my favorite equation
would be einstein's field equations from
general relativity
why do i feel that way well i have a
certain
nostalgia in some way for those
equations because they're the very
equations that i
so desperately wanted to understand as a
kid
which drove me to study physics and
ultimately
understand those equations or at least
as well as i can
you know those equations r mu minus a
half g minu
times r right
equals 8 pi g newton's constant over the
speed of light raised to the fourth
power times
t muni and
it's a geometry expression on the left
hand side it's a matter
energy expression on the right hand side
and that summarizes
einstein's brilliant breakthrough that
gravity which emerges from matter and
energy
is nothing but a geometrical property
of space and time and to me
to think about the geometry the
shape of space and time as being vital
to
the force of gravity that is just such a
beautiful idea
and the equation is such a simple
reflection of that idea
that there's nothing there's nothing
quite
like it bluesmokerh1 asks what is love
i don't know what is love well at one
level
[Music]
love is a human emotion and all human
emotions
emerge from my perspective and from
that of anybody who thinks about
themselves as a physicalist or a
materialist
emerges from the motion of particles
inside of a human body inside of a human
brain
and so love is simply a particular
pattern
of those quantum mechanical particle
motions
now framing it that way sounds
so mechanistic and so lacking in the
feeling of the poets that you could
easily turn to me and accuse me
of reducing the most
wondrous qualities of the world
to the most base description
and i don't accept that characterization
because
i am not saying that we should leave
a description of love in the
reductionist language
i'm saying that's useful to recognize
that human emotion
emerges from the very same particle
motion
that allows a piece of swiss cheese or
blue cheese or the moon or a
bottle of water or anything to emerge
everything physical in the universe
every physical process in the universe
is nothing but the quantum mechanical
motion of particles
period and a story and it's useful to
recognize that human emotion doesn't
stand outside that paradigm
having said that human emotion can
be experienced and it can be described
can be communicated at a whole variety
of
higher levels of coherence
and so we can describe human emotion in
the language
of the poet in the language of human
self
reflection and i am not saying that
that's a secondary language i'm not
saying that's a secondary description
i'm saying that the deepest
understanding of something like human
loves comes from an
amalgam of the description at the level
of human self-reflection
with the description given by
the great poets that have walked the
face of the earth
together with the description that
emerges from a quantum mechanical
understanding of matter when you blend
it all together
you have the richest understanding of
reality and in a sense that really is
the
a dominant theme in my latest book
which is trying to understand
the emergence of self-reflective
conscious beings and
to understand the kinds of behaviors
they undertake within the rubric
of a universe understood in terms of
its fundamental ingredients and its
fundamental
laws so blue smoker i don't know if
that's the kind of answer that you
were looking for but that's my response
to your very simple but deep question
about what is love and look i'll just
follow it up with a question from master
e.t
what is consciousness consciousness i
would describe in exactly the same
language
no difference whatsoever consciousness i
believe
i cannot prove nobody can consciousness
i believe
emerges from the physical processes
inside
of a brain or my consciousness emerges
from the physical processes inside of my
brain
the hard problem of consciousness that
philosophers struggle with that
psychologists struggle with that
thinkers struggle with is how can that
be
how can it be that the inner world of
self-reflective experience
how could it emerge from the motion of
electrons
and quarks and protons and neutrons
which themselves
seem to evidence no inner world
seem to have no ability to engage in
self-reflection that seems to be an
emergent property that only
comes on the scene when you have enough
particles in the correct arrangement but
how could it be
that particles that don't have inner
worlds can somehow yield
inner worlds i don't know the answer
nobody does
but i suspect that one day we will not
be as
puzzled by that mystery as we are today
especially
when we finally have sentient computers
artificial intelligence that really
convinces us
that they the system the computer
whatever convinces us that it is having
the same kind of
inner worlds that we have how will it do
that i i don't know but i mean if you
i may have said it before but if if i
walk
along central park
in new york in the far future if i'm
still here
and on a bench there is a computer maybe
it's even in the form of a humanoid
and that computer is like doubled over
in angst and i have a conversation with
the computer say what's wrong computer
and the computer says i'm
so i'm so concerned with the nature of
life i'm so concerned with how it is
that i'm having this
inner world of self-reflection how is it
possible the computer says to me
at that point i'll i think i'm likely to
be convinced unless someone's
maliciously just programmed the computer
to do
just that barring that possibility
i will be convinced that that computer
really is having an inner world
and at that point i will really be
convinced that inner worlds simply
emerge when particles
undertake certain processes and that
will be that at least
from my perspective so that that will be
my notion
of of how it we can talk about
what consciousness is now i'm being told
by some of you
that my um my video is out of focus
i forget how to fix the focus there's
some advanced setting on this camera
that i don't know so what i'm going to
do for half a second is
i'm going to shut my video for a split
second and hopefully it'll
come back and look better i don't know
hopefully that helped otherwise i'm not
sure how to i forget how to
how to do it for this camera so maybe
someone can tell me if it's really
continues to be out of focus all right
so other
questions um what do we got here
um uh pranav
krishnasami any updates on the general
relativity course in world science u i
i i answer that question by first
hanging my head in shame
i've been promising that course for like
six
years oh my goodness five years or
something like that
well here's the update you know i'm not
i'm not able to go
back uh to to normal life nobody is
and so we're gonna have the opportunity
i think over the next few months
to in our seclusion create some new
things that
otherwise i wouldn't have had time to do
without traveling and
my teaching will be all online so i am
hopeful
that i'll produce a new world science eu
course i mean a full course not a master
class but a full course
and i was thinking of not doing general
relativity and again
you guys chime in because you guys are
are part of that audience
what i am thinking is that i would do a
course on quantum mechanics
i mean a full course on quantum
mechanics you know soup to nuts as they
say
starting with the basic idea of
classical physics
the motivation for quantum mechanics
really get into schrodinger's equation
spend some time on the interpretational
issues give you some
of the mathematical technology for those
of you who are interested
to to analyze systems quantum
mechanically and then
end the course with some philosophical
speculations about what quantum
mechanics is really telling us about the
nature of the world
if that is a course that some of you
would like please let me know
if some of you would far prefer the
general relativity course let me know
there
too but that that is the i'm i'm really
hopeful that i'll be able to produce
that by
by january so so don't hold me to it
but uh that is what i'm thinking now uh
having said that
let me ask you guys one other question
and you know there's like this time
delay in the stream so i won't see
your your answer in in in real time but
i'll see it 20 seconds
later and so if i don't catch what you
say i'll look back at it later
but i want to continue doing these uh
these
these your daily equation live sessions
we probably should change the name but
i'm so used to it now
but um number one it'd be really good
feedback if you enjoyed
the conversation with adam reese for
those of you who were here for the first
hour if you weren't here you know don't
don't say anything
but if you were hurt let me know because
i think that's something that we're
planning to do
for subsequent of sessions we'll bring
in
more of the faculty from world science
you number one
and question number two is timing
because it turns out that i do have to
go back to teaching at columbia columbia
university is where
i i suspect maybe some of you know maybe
you don't know
i'm professor of physics and mathematics
at columbia
and the term is starting up and one of
the courses that i'm teaching
meets on fridays from
2 p.m to 5 p.m which as you will no
doubt
note conflicts with this time period so
if i
have to change i do have to change the
time what should i change the time too
my thought is
what if we still keep it on friday but
just me earlier
like 11 to 1 11 to 2 depending on how
much energy i have
eleven to two be tight i'd have to go
right from three hours with you guys to
three hours of my class that may be hard
but just friday mornings work what do
you think about that or should i just do
a different day
like thursdays from from two to five or
something like that
so i'm more than happy for you guys to
chime in with a suggestion
on what time we should use as we go
forward
in the future but let me leave that
at that and go back to some of the
physics questions
that you guys have been asking so i'm
going to scroll back to see what i've
got
here and
monjeb's tv asks according to string
theory when particles collide
some of the energy goes to another
dimension and energy may also come from
another dimension to ours that is all
true could it be that some of that
energy is dark energy that is a very
good question and let me just note a few
things
you don't even have to
who asked this question monjeb's tv mon
jabs you don't even have to have
the exchange of energy between the
various dimensions to have
the potential for the extra dimensions
to be intimately
involved and perhaps even explain the
dark energy
that i was talking about with adam it's
a highly speculative idea
but you have to bear in mind the extra
dimensions of string theory
they're not located at some
particular spot in our dimensions
they're
everywhere they're located everywhere in
our dimensions i mean what's a good
example of that
i have this um this little piece of
paper here
just happened to have it but i'm gonna
roll this piece of paper up
it's an instruction manual for something
i don't remember what it was
but here that piece of paper is now a
tube right
and if i was to make this tube ever
tighter in its
circular girth its circular dimension
it'll become so skinny that you don't
see it right so you would
think that all i had in my hand was
a line you wouldn't see the thickness if
i made it sufficiently small but of
course
there is a circular part to the paper
it's just harder to see
but my point is this if i were to ask
you
where is the circular part where was the
extra
curled up dimension for the piece of
paper you wouldn't point to one location
along this linear dimension you'd point
to every location
there's a circle here there's another
circle right next to it
there's a circle here there's a circle
here and right down the line
circle after circle after circle after
circle so the extra dimensions
in this curled up piece of paper exist
everywhere
along the linear dimension that we can
easily see
and that's the model for how we think
about extra dimensions and string theory
some dimensions are big and obvious to
see
like the linear dimension of the curled
up piece of paper and those dimensions
in space we call left right back fourth
and up down those are the three
dimensions of everyday experience
string theory says there are extra
dimensions where are they
well like with the circle in the curled
up piece of paper they're everywhere
the extra dimensions are here and here
and here and here and here so they're
all over the place they permeate space
that's very interesting for many reasons
but it's very
interesting for dark energy this energy
that suffuses
space that we don't see why is it
interesting well imagine
that those extra dimensions of space
each harbor some energy
where would that energy be well that
energy then would be everywhere
throughout our three dimensions of space
because the extra dimensions
exist everywhere throughout our three
dimensions
of space that begins to sound
like dark energy dark energy is energy
that fills space
that we don't see if there's energy in
the extra dimensions which we don't see
and those extra dimensions are
everywhere in space and energy itself
will fill
space so that's an interesting idea and
it's one that some people have developed
i
wrote a paper a few years ago on this
idea
with a physicist named jan 11. some of
you may know
jen 11 she also has written some
wonderful books
most recently black hole blues
about gravitational waves and anyway so
we wrote this paper some
years ago suggesting that the dark
energy
might be bound up with a quantum
mechanical source of energy called the
casimir force or the casimir energy
that naturally would give energy to
these curled up
portions of space and an answer that's a
long answer to
mon jeb's question that we suggest it
might be the dark energy there are there
are
challenges with making this idea fully
work
but we did write out some of the
mathematics of this and at least
in principle i consider it an idea that
that it's a dark horse candidate but
you're talking about dark energy
so perhaps a dark horse kennedy is the
right thing
but it is at least a possibility that
the dark energy that
we believe fills our space may indeed
originate in the energy that suffuses
the extra dimensions that a theory like
string theory posits to be out there
okay so that's a great question and
allowed for a lot of physics
but if there is a follow-up on that man
jebs feel free to
ask it jordan where jordan wire where
asks hey brian how is string theory
doing these days just fine
i will say the last i checked there were
a lot of problems that needed to be
solved well
that's a healthy state of any vibrant
cutting-edge field of research once
you've run out of problems
the the theory is done have any of these
been figured out
in say the last 10-ish years thanks and
the answer that is yes
so there are you know tremendous amount
of unsolved
issues in string theory that's why it
still keeps people
generations of physicists busy but
many questions that i would say
physicists thought would be beyond our
ability to address
in say a 10-year time frame say like 20
years ago that
they posited or imagined would not be
addressable
or not would not be addressed 10 years
later which would be 10 years ago
to match with jordan's time frame had
been addressed
for instance we even have
non-perturbative formulations of the
theory
for a very long time all we had were
approximate formulations of the theory
and now in certain environments certain
space-time environments we have exact
of the theory there are certain
descriptions of black holes that i don't
think anybody thought we'd fully
understand within string theory and
there are certain aspects
of those descriptions now we do
understand now those have raised even
more questions and that's sort of the
nature of
research you solve question number one
and the very solution that you put
forward now allows you to ask
questions you couldn't even ask you
couldn't even imagine before
so so yes the theory is alive it's well
it's making progress
the big question though that we've not
really been able to
make much headway on is whether this
theory can describe
actual physics observations experiments
that we can do
today or in the not too distant future
and that's the only way that we're
really going to know whether the theory
is an interesting piece of mathematics
that might on
paper put together quantum mechanics in
the general theory of relativity but
beyond that it's not
actually relevant to the physics of our
world it could be the case that that's
what string theory is
to go beyond that we really need the
theory to make a prediction or explain
some observation that happens out there
in the real world
and except for the most prosaic of
things
string theory has not distinguished
itself in that domain
as yet and that's that's where we hope
things will change
okay good question uh jordan also
the previous one by mon jobs is a good
question as well
so i'm going to scroll you know there's
so many comments here that it's
always hard to stop
on one that is
[Music]
relevant to the kinds of things that
we're talking about today but i'm again
happy to go elsewhere
so a random question rigid asks
is is warp drive possible and
there are warp drive ideas that emerge
in the general theory of relativity it's
one thing for something to be
possible that is not incompatible with
the laws
that we understand it's quite another to
claim that we will realize that
possibility
so i would say that there are warp drive
like scenarios that people imagine in
the general theater relativity but we're
nowhere
nowhere near realizing them so don't
think that anyone's going to be
on a starship asking for warp 9 anytime
soon okay anas asks can you do a daily
equation
on your paper dark energy and
stabilization of extra dimension so that
is the paper that i was just referring
to an answer to
mon job's question punjab tv
dark energy and the stabilization of
extra dimensions can i do a daily
equation
i could um it's really a matter of
finding
the time with so much to do but i will
keep that in mind
and maybe one weekend you know the kids
are out maybe uh playing tennis or
looking for frogs that's unlikely my
kids don't really look for frogs much
these days but if i have a
free half hour i will try to sit down
and do that
yeah the daily equation on that paper
would be kind of fun
sandeep asked can you please confirm
that a conscious entity
is not needed to be an observer in a
quantum mechanical experiment for
example a detector one of the
slits can make the observation and
sandeep i do agree
with you when we talk about quantum
mechanics and
the role of the observer
to me observer is a stand-in
for any physical system conscious or not
that's able to interact with the system
that's being studied
and interact with it in such a way that
the interaction itself
disambiguates the quantum mechanical
possibilities what i mean by that well
in any physical system described by
quantum mechanics which is
any physical system because quantum
mechanics rules across the board
you're in a situation that the quantum
laws predict the probabilities for one
or another outcome but as far as we
understand things today
the quantum laws don't select one or the
other
outcome all of those outcomes that have
non-zero probability
are in principle possible but yet
when an observer makes an observation
only one of those outcomes is actually
found
and so i would define an observer as any
physical system
that can interact with a system that
you're interested in that you're
studying
can interact with it sufficiently
to ensure that one of those
outcomes is selected and
i do not believe that you need
consciousness to play that role
can i prove that i can't why can't i
because
i can't become aware of that singular
result
that one outcome from the many that
quantum mechanics allowed i can't become
aware of it without my consciousness
being part of the story
so the very fact that consciousness
cannot be aware of something without
consciousness
means i can't be aware of my
physical device
having disambiguated the possibilities
without actually
looking at the meter and seeing one
outcome and then you could say to me
it was not the case that one result had
been selected by that
non-conscious piece of equipment it was
only when you looked with your
consciousness
that that piece of equipment was
realizing one outcome from one
state of the observed system so i can't
prove it but
cindy my strong belief is that
consciousness is not special
to the quantum formalism others may
disagree with that and i'd be happy to
hear
from anyone who does in the comments
section so quantum mechanic
asked brian we know nature is quantum
mechanical
so why is so much effort going into
quantifying a classical theory like
general relativity rather than
begin with quantum mechanics and search
for space-time gravity as an emergent
phenomenon so look quantum mechanics
you're you're right but you're
describing a state of affairs that's
very sophisticated
when we study
most physical systems we make use
of a paradigm that was laid down
you know roughly 100 years ago is we
understand the system as best we can
with classical physics
and then there's a process by which we
sew
quantum mechanics into the formalism we
quantize
the classical system and you're right we
shouldn't do that
if we really were fully
enlightened quantum mechanical beings
we would start with quantum mechanics
from the start
it's a funny sentence we would start
with quantum mechanics from the start
we would begin our mathematical analysis
with
the quantum formalism as opposed to
begin with the classical formalism and
then
overlay quantum mechanics on top of it
but for many physical systems we just
don't know how to do that
we still use classical physics as our
way in to our
partial understanding of the system be
it
baseballs be it atoms
be it a light itself right
even in the study of light we begin with
maxwell's equations
maxwell's equations are classical
equations
they're partial differential equations
that don't know about
quantum physics that describe how
electric
and magnetic fields influence each other
and in that way give rise to propagating
wave disturbances that we call
light in order to make that quantum
mechanical we take
maxwell's classical equations and we run
them through an algorithm
that algorithm is called the
quantization algorithm
and using that algorithm we can yield
quantum mechanical versions of maxwell's
equations
and when we use those equations to
describe things like photons
and electrons and how they interact the
quantized maxwell equations work
fantastically well
wow that is a beautiful
trajectory from ignorance to
understanding
but in a more enlightened way of going
about things we would simply
write down the quantum mechanical
description of electricity and magnetism
from the get-go
no one really knows how to do that
without
relying even in some hidden way
on our classical understanding and so
when it comes to the general theory of
relativity we similarly
would imagine we start with einstein's
equations and try to quantize them now
that's an approach
that is taken by one particular school
of thought
loop quantum gravity if you will is an
approach that
takes more or less that perspective
that einstein's classical equations are
the starting point and we
inject quantum mechanics to that that is
not
the approach that we take in string
theory
so in string theory what we do is
we introduce a holy secondary idea
which is that matter is made up of
vibrating filaments called strings
these linear filaments of energy they
vibrate in different ways and that's a
system that we can describe using
classical physics
anyone who's taken basic classical
physics one of the systems that you
study is
the vibrating string and we know how to
write down the equation for that indeed
we know how to write the equation for
that
including relativity so the relativistic
version of the vibrating string
and then in essence and string theory we
quantize that classical equation
so we're not quantizing the general
theory of relativity in string theory
the way the loop quantum gravity people
do
we're quantizing the motion of a
filament
and then the remarkable thing is when we
study
the equations that emerge from
quantizing
the vibrations of a string lo and behold
within that
system we unexpectedly
bump into einstein's equations in the
general theory of relativity but now we
are in a quantum mechanical description
so we get a quantum description of
gravity
by quantizing the classical vibrations
of a string who
would have thought that that's like
crazy talk but it's true
so in answer to your question and i
forget who asked this question
i don't know sorry whoever asked this
question it's a good one
but in some sense the loop quantum
gravity people are following the more
prosaic trajectory quantizing einstein's
equation and look then they do all sorts
of
miraculous and wonderful things that
that are not
obvious and are deeply creative so i
don't want in any way take away from
what they do
but the string theorists approach to
quantum gravity is far more indirect
it is not simply taking einstein's
equations and quantizing them
it's doing this other intermediate step
of introducing the motion of a vibrating
filament recognizing that within the
quantum mechanical description of
that vibrating filament we have
einstein's general theory of relativity
and then saying aha string theory gives
us a quantum theory of gravity
that's the approach that we take
which is quite quite different all
alrighty so
anything else you guys would like to
talk about i'm going to scroll through
here
and um anas about
salham in capital letters tells me that
i found a way to unite gravity with
electromagnetism in four-dimensional
space-time
and and in us look you may have
discovered the final theory i'm not
taking it away from you i have no idea
what you found i can't pass judgment on
it and
i don't mean this in a mean way but i
don't even want you to send me your
ideas i'll tell you why
i get so many unified theories sent to
me
through ordinary mail at columbia
through my
email which is not that hard to find
that i could make a full-time job of
reading other people's proposed papers
on
unification rather but i'd rather you do
annas is take your paper and send it to
one of the journals
journals are set up for the refereeing
process and if the referee
thinks that your idea has promised we'll
send it out
to be judged by a member of the
community maybe that'll be me
i don't know although i have to tell you
journal editors don't send me papers as
frequently as they used to because i am
really slow
in reviewing them because i got so many
other things going on but that's a
footnote
but on us my point is number one if you
really think you have the deep theory
send it to a journal go through the
review process
but the point i want to make is that
simply uniting gravity with
electromagnetism
is not that hard if you're talking about
classical ravaging classical
electromagnetism in fact we have an
algorithm for doing that
the simplest way to do it is you simply
look at the approach to classical
physics
that's called the least action principle
you write down an
action you write down the einstein
hilbert action
for gravity and you add to it the action
for electromagnetism which anyone who
studied electromagnetism knows that that
action is
f mu nu contracted with
f mu nu where f mu nu is the derivative
of the four vector potential a so
f mu is d mu a new
minus d new a mu and the contraction of
f mu nu
with f mu nu that is you contract them
with
the metric tensor on the
four-dimensional space-time manifold
that you're studying and you add that to
the einstein hilbert action and there
you have a unification of gravity and
electromagnetism in four-dimensional
space time and a story
we know how to do that the more
difficult thing
is writing down a quantum mechanical
union
of general relativity and say
electromagnetism that works in an
arbitrarily curved space-time
environment
the quantum mechanical story is less
obvious
you can try taking that action and
putting it in the quantum mechanical
version that makes use of the action
which is known as the feynman sum over
histories
so now if you want the transition
amplitude between quantum state 1 and
quantum state 2
you look at the transition probability
that you get by integrating over all
field configurations that join the
initial configuration with the final
configuration weighted by
e to the i action over h bar
sorry for talking in technical language
but i think many of you
know what i'm talking about here that
however doesn't work
for gravity or at least it's hard to
make it work for gravity and if you use
a standard approach
so if you can solve that problem and us
then i think you really have something
and that's worthy of sending to a
journal
but a classical union of gravity and
electromagnetism
is something we know how to do
okay let's see what else we got here
scrolling down the questions maybe i
should scroll up the questions there
are a bunch here
donatello asks couldn't you tell you're
at the edge of the universe
if all the galaxies you see are to one
side but not the
other and yeah you could
in principle i mean if if our universe
had a wall out there
and actually there are some real
theories that suggest that there is a
a version of string theory where
one of the 11 dimensions is compactified
on a line interval and if that's the
case
and you could move along that extra
dimension that line interval
is finite in size and you'd hit a
boundary
and that boundary would be the edge of
the universe so these ideas are not as
as ridiculous as they might sound and
yeah if there is a boundary to the
universe and you happen to be right next
to the boundary
then what you see toward the interior
would be different from what you see
as you look to the boundary and yeah you
know that you're there
possible but that's not what we see is
the point what we see when we look out
into the universe
is what appears to be
appropriately interpreting the data a
universe that's homogeneous
and isotropic these are ideas that
that adam briefly mentioned i don't know
if he used that language but he yeah he
did he used exactly that language now
that i think about it in our earlier
discussion from 3 to 4 pm
and if those of you have come late go
check out we had an interesting
conversation with nobel laureate
adam reese between three and four
associated with world science u
but he mentioned that the universe is
homogeneous and isotropic by which we
mean
that if you look out in any direction it
seems to be
more or less on average like looking out
in any other direction
and moreover if i was to transport my
location to any other place in the
universe
the view from that location on average
would be the same
as the view that i have from here
homogeneity and
isotropy but if the universe was not
homogeneous
it was not homogeneous and isotropic
sorry starting to get dry mouth as we
enter into our third hour here so i need
to uh
wet my whistle as they say if the
universe were not
homogeneous and isotropic then our
theories of cosmology would be quite
different
and in the most dramatic case that
donatella is suggesting
if we were to look out in a direction
and see a brick wall
that would certainly affect the way we
mathematically model reality we simply
don't see that
not that it's impossible but our most
precise
experiments have not revealed that road
runner
has a very cryptic equation as
a question roadrunner says er equals epr
and that is perhaps one of the deepest
suggestions to emerge in the last few
years
er equals epr and it's an especially
timely moment to discuss that equation
er
equals epr because er refers to a paper
that einstein
wrote with his colleague rosen in 1935
which is 85 years ago and in that paper
they
introduced what's known as the einstein
rosen bridge
which in more sci-fi language that we
physicists
also use is known as a wormhole
a tunnel through space epr
which is the right hand side of
roadrunner's equation
refers to another paper that einstein
wrote in 1935
this time with two colleagues one of
whom was also rosen
but the p was podolski boris podolski
and i do not think that einstein thought
that these papers had
anything to do with each other because
the first paper as i mentioned had to do
with wormholes and the second paper epr
has to do with quantum entanglement
nobody thought that there was a
relationship between these ideas at all
but in recent years led by juan
maldasena
at the institute for advanced study led
by lenny gross
lenny gross lenny suskind lenny gross
brain faltering moment there my good
friend leonard
suskind at stanford
there is a suggestion on the table that
those two 1935 papers
may be deeply connected and that's what
this er equals epr
is all about roughly speaking the idea
is
that quantum entanglement two particles
that are quantum entangled there may be
in some sense a secret wormhole
that is connecting them so the epr of
quantum entanglement
may secretly be the er the einstein
rosen bridge
of that other 1935 paper so we're
actually going to have a conversation
at this year's world science festival on
exactly that subject
i'm not sure when that program will be
out
obviously we're doing it fully digitally
but we're going to have a conversation
that will involve i believe i believe
lenny suskind will be in that program
as will be some of the folks who
are experts in quantum entanglement
i don't think zeilinger has
said whether he'll be in the program yet
i hope he will be
if you know anton zeilinger and you're
maybe in his research group i mean i
know him
but if you're in his research group
maybe hit him from another angle and say
hey
it'd be fun to do that program so i'd
love for him to be part of it if he has
the time
and we will discuss er equals epr so in
the next few months look for a program
from the world science festival that
will
explain this idea in accessible detail
but in more detail than
i have time or even expertise to discuss
here
right now okay other
other questions that we might oh here
goes
one that not quite scientific but uh
those are always kind of fun i don't
know who said it but somebody just asked
what was the last
movie that i saw and sorry i can't
it went by too fast and i don't know who
asked that
but uh i'll answer the question what's
the last movie i saw
the last movie i saw was
selma i'm pretty certain that's the last
movie
i saw which
very timely movie you know about the uh
the civil rights activism
that was led by people like john lewis
who just died us congressperson
and uh it was a wonderful movie before
that i think this
movies that i saw were the uh were seven
of the eight
harry potter films that my son had me
watch they were great to see i'd never
seen any of them before and um yeah
whatever expect his patronus or whatever
it is
he'll correct my uh my harry potter
lingo no doubt patronum or something
like that
yeah so that's uh that is the uh the
last
movie that i saw um okay
um shivam asks
uh please listen to me brian okay i'm
listening why is action such a
big deal in theoretical physics why is
it so beautiful
well there actually is a daily equation
that a full episode that i did
on the least action principle so
in more detail i would suggest if you
want to see the equations which i won't
do here right now
you can go back to that iteration of
your daily equation but why isn't such a
big deal here's why it's such a big deal
in physics and in our observation of the
world
we encounter so many distinct phenomena
right
you got whatever you got shooting stars
you got the motion of planets
you've got the motion of baseballs hit
by a bat you've got the motion
of electric and magnetic ripples through
an electromagnetic field i mean you've
got
a wealth of different physical phenomena
and so naively you would think you have
a wealth of different mathematical
descriptions of that wealth of different
physical phenomena
but amazingly at least speaking
classically for a moment
amazingly the equations that describe
all of those phenomena we have found all
emerge from one basic principle and that
is the principle of least action
which is roughly speaking the idea that
associated with any physical system
is a quantity called the action and
every physical system
if they differ sufficiently they have a
different formula for their action
but if you minimize the formula for the
action of a physical system
the equations that result from
minimizing that action are the classical
equations that govern that system
so here you've got a wealth of physical
phenomenon
that can be described mathematically
by a single algorithm write down
the action that's relevant for that
system
which if you care about it is the
kinetic energy minus the potential
energy
so you write down the kinetic energy
minus the potential energy that's
relevant for that physical system you
minimize it and the equations that ensue
are the equations
wow right what a
beautiful unity at the core
of classical physics that all of
classical physics can be reduced
to finding the minimization or the
extremization
of this quantity called an action
when you go to quantum physics richard
feynman showed that
that unity carries over in a far more
complicated way
but as i mentioned before you now take
that action
you exponentiate it you put an i in
front of the action so you're looking at
e to the i
action you divide through by planck's
constant h bar
and then to find the quantum mechanical
properties of that system
you do the path integral the sum over
all histories
that that system can engage in weighted
by e to the i
action over h bar that's a little bit
more complicated i don't expect you to
understand that if you haven't studied
the path into approach to quantum
mechanics but my point
is even quantum mechanically
all physical phenomenon slot
into the same rubric path integral
where the dominant term the essential
term
in that sum involves the action so that
is the answer
to why the action is so beautiful and
how
it is so ubiquitous in our understanding
of physical law
uh shavok mandal says i read your book
until the end of time and there you
describe
boltzmann brains but i didn't understand
that can you explain it to me
okay i'm happy to do that chevoke
so in the far
far future as i explain in until the end
of time
i use the metaphor of you know walking
up the empire state building and
letting each floor represent the
logarithm say of the time scale so
floor 50 would represent the time scale
10 to the 50 and
for a hundred would represent the time
scale 10 to 100 years since the big bang
that's the units that i use but the
numbers are so big that
it doesn't matter what unit you use and
what i argue for is that in the far
future the universe
will have decayed it will have
disintegrated
even black holes will have evaporated
and all that will remain
are particles that are wafting through
the void that's the
fate that awaits all
matter all complex matter and you could
at that point say that that's it
that's the end of time right once
everything is just disintegrated into
particles wafting through the void
the particles continue to meander this
way and that but
but that's it and for a very very very
long time
that would be a correct assessment
that nothing happens and therefore you
call it the end of time
but if you wait exponential of
exponential times like 10 to the 10 to
the 68 years
not 10 to the 68 years not the 68th
floor of the empire state building in
our logarithmic visualization but rather
a 10 raised to the 10 raised to the
68th power over those time scales
something else can happen and what can
happen is
even the random motion of particles in
the void every so often
can cause them to collide and stick
together
and yield interesting agglomerations
interesting conglomerates
of particles and among the interesting
conglomerates of particles that on rare
occasion
can spontaneously form from particles
wafting through the void
the configuration that can emerge is
that of a human brain
a human brain is just a constellation of
particles as i mentioned before
and so if you wait long enough on the
order of 10 to the 10 to the 68 years
then just the
random motion of particles through the
void can cause them to
overlap to coalesce into a structure
whose physical configuration is that of
a human brain
and that's what's known as a boltzmann
brain a boltzmann brain
is a brain that forms out there in the
void of space
from the random motions of particles
obviously it is a rare occurrence and
that's why i mentioned
you'd have to wait at least 10 to the 10
to the 68 years to have a fighting
chance for this to happen
but if a brain did form out there in the
void the
suspicion the hypothesis the speculation
is that that brain would think i mean
literally if that brain
happened to have the particulate
arrangement
that my brain is enjoying right now
then that brain out there in the void
would think it's me
that boltzmann brain would have the
thoughts that i'm having right now
because that brain
by hypothesis has the same particulate
arrangement as my brain and nothing but
the particulate arrangement determines
the inner world that i'm now
experiencing
so that brain in the void would think
it's having
a live session in a little room in
upstate
new york sitting in front of a camera
and having a conversation called your
daily equation live
that brain in the void that boltzmann
brain would think it's having that
experience
now that brain you wouldn't expect to
last very long
because space is inhospitable to brains
that are just
floating there but you know you can
imagine even
more extreme circumstances more extreme
particle configurations in which
not only does a brain form but maybe
a body and maybe a planet and maybe a
solar system and therefore you could
imagine that the random motion of
particles could
spontaneously cause the whole thing that
i'm familiar with
to emerge in the void and that sets up
an interesting conundrum because then
how do i know that i am not now
that brain i don't
i could be a boltzmann brain in the void
that's a possibility
i think it's unlikely but it's something
that we have to
admit the possibility of and in my book
and in
you know who asked this question
somebody asked this question now shabook
mandala said
so when you read about this in until the
end of time my point there
in those late chapters not to convince
you that we are boltzmann brains
although we could be but rather to note
that physicists pretty much use
boltzmann brains as a diagnostic tool
if our theories really allow for
boltzmann brains we
question our theories or if our theories
make
boltzmann brains likely we question our
theories we are more interested in
theories
that don't set up this skepticism
that what we see here is real and
boltzmann brain certainly do set up that
skepticism because that brain floating
in the void even though it thinks me me
thinks it is me and thinks that it's
having my experience and has all of my
memories none of those
memories are real because they just were
imprinted on that brain by virtue of
the highly choreographed motion of
particles reproducing my brain out there
in the void
and that really sets up a kind of
skeptical nightmare
where we if we buy into this view can't
trust anything
we can't even trust the very
observations that support the general
theory of relativity and quantum
mechanics which are themselves
vital to concluding that there could be
boltzmann brains at all
so everything that you care about winds
up
having its legs cut out from under it if
you buy into this boltzmann brain
perspective and that's why many of us
hope that our theories
will one day steer clear of this
possibility show
why this possibility can't be true but
that
i hope that clarifies what boltzmann
brains are
and why it is that people talk about
them
so chris mortlock asks apologies if this
is a somewhat
dumb question don't worry about it man
we're all
just here hanging out not judging
i'm no science expert but i read that
atoms are mostly empty space
but what sort of empty is this is it a
vacuum of some sort or something else
that's a great
question chris great question
in fact you know my my daughter
who's with us up here as my son is too
decided to take an online chemistry
class
this past week i was really surprised
pleasantly surprised
that she she actually took an online
camera and had to pay for this chemistry
class this is free
right she gotta pay 60
for five hour long chemistry lessons
but it was worth it she learned all
about the various atomic models
that have been developed over time and
she actually made a version of the
rutherford
model which is the solar system like
model where you've got the electrons
going around the nucleus
and as chris notes between the electrons
and the nucleus it is mostly empty space
like my daughter she made it out of you
know coat hangers
put the electrons on the coat hangers
and you got the nucleus hanging from you
know the top of the coat hanger but it's
empty space between them
and i told her if you made that model to
scale
and your proton is the size of a ping
ping-pong ball
then your electrons i haven't worked it
out but your electrons would be like you
know
like miles away that's how much empty
space there is if the proton's like a
ping-pong ball
i think i once worked this out that if
the proton was the size
of a ping pong ball that my daughter
used but rather the size of a p
then the electrons would be sort of in
the bleachers in yankee stadium if the
p was on the pitcher's mound so
anyway i don't know if those details are
correct but the point is
there's a huge amount of empty space
between the electrons and the nucleus
and chris mortlock asks
what kind of empty is that and the idea
is that it's not the vacuum in the sense
of the a region of space that's
completely devoid of
any matter because protons have
positive charge electrons have negative
charge which means that they are
surrounded by
an electromagnetic field so you've got
electromagnetic field that's
you know permeating around the particles
and it spills off into space overall the
atom is neutral
because the positive of the nucleus
cancels against the negative
of the electrons but there's a lot of
interesting electromagnetic phenomenon
that's happening within
the empty space of
the atom so on average we would say that
that space has zero energy on
average we would say it's truly empty
but there are all sorts of
electromagnetic fields that are
fluctuating up fluctuating down quantum
processes with particles popping into
existence
and disappearing as they annihilate
against each other
so it's kind of a seething arena of
activity which is pretty different
from the placid version of the vacuum
that
i think we often have in mind when we're
thinking about empty
space in that language so the empty
space
inside an atom is a complex arena
it is not as simple as the name would
suggest
okay so priyank dash
asked me a question uh dog about my
daughter
which class is she in she's in um
going into seventh grade i guess so it
was a sixth grade
type chemistry class over the uh the
summer i don't know any more detail than
that i hope that addresses the question
so uh what else do we have here guys um
so many questions so little time what
should i take um
um mshare asks why
why why in equals mc squared is light
the conversion factor what is unique
about light
good question and
the special thing about light of course
is that it's a universal number it's a
number that everyone agrees on
regardless
of their motion or where they are if
they correctly calculate the speed of
light
you get a number that everybody will
agree on
so the real special thing about equals m
c
squared is that the conversion between
mass
and energy is a universal conversion
it's not a conversion that fluctuates
not a conversion you know when you when
you
go from euros to dollars
that conversion changes from moment to
moment
as the monetary factors
affect the
ways in which dollars and euros are
selled back and forth
sold not selled sold back and forth to
one another
that's not the case with the conversion
with the equals mt squared it's a fixed
value once and for all and that's really
the importance of the c squared there
what's also important about the c
squared and perhaps somewhat surprising
is that
in everyday units c squared is a big
number
which means if you measure mass in
everyday units
and then you multiply by c square this
huge number in everyday units
the energy you're getting in everyday
units is big
so that should help your intuition that
small amount of matter can yield lot
amount
of energy right we know this from you
know the devastating nuclear
weapons that were used to conclude world
war
ii only had you know a couple of pounds
couple of kilograms of
fissile material that was actually
actively engaged
in the processes that yield the energy
and yet even though there were a couple
kilos
the energetic output was devastating
deadly devastating but other than that
the c-squared
is not as fundamental as it might seem
it's universal it doesn't change in
everyday units it's a big number
now i think you're also asking so like
why is it there
and the reason why it's there
is that the special theory of relativity
which
einstein used to show
that e equals m c squared the special
theory of relativity
is not a theory about relativity per se
in fact einstein himself wanted to call
special relativity
in variance it doesn't quite have the
same
ring as special relativity but to him
what we call special relativity was not
about
motion being relative and things of that
sort it was really about the things that
are not
relative it was the things that are
invariant it was about identifying
qualities of the world
that are independent of your motion and
the fact that the speed of light is one
of those things
is deeply surprising because speeds
typically do depend on your state of
motion
but if you think about special
relativity as in variance theory and you
think about the speed of light as the
ultimate invariant
the ultimate number that doesn't change
and if you recognize as einstein showed
us that equals mc squared emerges from
relativity
now perhaps it's not that surprising
that the dominant
invariant quantity c emerges in the
dominant invariant equation
equals m c squared and the fact that
it's c squared
the two that it's squared that's just in
order to make the units to work out
if you write down the natural units for
an energy in the natural units for a
mass
then you have to multiply the mass units
by a length squared over a time squared
in order to get the natural units of an
energy and that's why
c squared comes in as opposed to c
i hope that addresses the question
there's no real full answer
to your question but i hope that sort of
chips away at the confusion by
shining little brief
moments of illumination on the question
wow that answer had a lot of metaphors i
think it's just metaphored myself out no
more metaphors for the
remaining time that we have together
okay so
oh what else do we have um
uh um
caramatt asks why should we know
everything and
and uh caramatt if that's how your name
is pronounced no we we shouldn't
and i don't think we necessarily ever
will i think it's an ongoing process of
discovery to try to understand how the
world works
but in no way can anyone
establish that the human brain has the
capacity
to understand all the deep truths of
reality
i think i gave this example before but i
think it's worth
recounting you know
during the first hour if you were here
when i was talking to adam reese
you know that you heard my dog barking
for a period of time
my dog is smart i'm pretty we got two
dogs
i'm pretty sure that was scarlet
scarlett is a smart dog maybe she's even
listening to the stream
right now but there are things about the
nature of reality that i
pretty much suspect that scarlet cannot
grasp
i do not think a dog mine or any other
can grass schrodinger's equation
of quantum mechanics i do not think that
my dog scarlet or any other dog can
grasp the einstein field equations
i could be wrong scarlet and other dogs
listening to this dream may be
collectively rolling their eyes
as under their breath they bark out how
silly that human being is we all
learn schrodinger's
when we're puppies that may be happening
i don't think so
and yet what this means therefore
is that there are smart beings on the
planet that are limited in what they can
discern about the nature of reality
and why should we be any different from
the dog
why should we necessarily
have the mental acuity the mental
expansiveness the mental capacity
to understand the ultimate deep truths
of the world
the answer is we may not the answer is
we've done really well so far
pat ourselves on our collective backs
for
developing quantum mechanics and using
it to
understand the electrons magnetic moment
its magnetic properties
to better than one part and ten to the
twelfth
i'm not joking when i say that every
member of the species deserves to stand
up and take a bow for that achievement
because we're all responsible for it
it is an achievement of a small group of
individuals
but those individuals could not do the
calculations that they do if it wasn't
for the
mass activity of
our brethren over the course of
thousands of generations that allows us
to be here at all
so we should be proud of what we've been
able to figure out
no doubt about that but it would be
hubris to say that this particular
physical structure called the human
brain
has the ability to understand every
truth about the world
i'm not talking about encyclopedic
capacity to store
every truth about the world i'm saying
that maybe even the deep
true laws of physics and perhaps those
laws are articulated by one equation
we perhaps have been unable to find that
equation we perhaps would be unable to
understand that equation even if it was
revealed to us by some
alien super race
so there's no reason to believe
that we won't at some point get stuck
now the amazing thing is we've not yet
gotten stuck look what we have been able
to figure out not just the electron's
magnetic moment
we've been able to work out equations
that allow us to peer back to a brief
second after the beginning we've worked
out equations that allow us to
understand
how time elapses in different
circumstances equations
that allow us to understand as we spoke
about in the first hour how space
expands equations that have allowed us
to peer with our equations
into the far future and understand the
kind of fate
that awaits us as described in my book
until the end of time and as we
recounted here that black holes will
evaporate
between the 68th and the hundredth floor
of the empire state building between
time scales 10 to the 68 and 10 to the
100
from the big bang we've been able to
work out the
weird possibility that in 10 to the 10
to the 68 years we might have boltzmann
brains something we discussed in answer
to another question these are
really wonderful achievements
we've not yet gotten stuck but we may
get stuck
it may be the case that we'll have to
say
wait for the brain to evolve
into a more robust structure
before the next leap in human
understanding can take place
is that possible yeah that is definitely
possible sherry asks when we say
light is a disturbance of the
electromagnetic field
doesn't mean that the electromagnetic
field actually covers all 3d space
so it weighs when there is a disturbance
as in light
and i think that's a fine way of
thinking about it shari
think about the electromagnetic field
when it's in its
most docile least energetic
state from a classical perspective
imagine that the electric
and magnetic fields say far away from
any sources far away from any electrons
far away from any magnets
that that field drops ever closer to
zero
so if there is a large expanse of
empty space in the classical intuitive
sense
the electromagnetic field will drop to
zero but it's still there
much as you suggest even though its
value
is zero the field is still there and so
when we
disturb that field by causing some
charges to accelerate
sending out a disturbance that ripples
through that field
there is a field to be rippled already
in place
if you will and this disturbance
just ripples through it so i think
that's a fine way
of thinking about that shari
somebody uh keeps talking about road
runner i'm not sure
if there's an actual question there but
stephen brown asks
is a magnetic monopole possible
what's a magnetic monopole well
let's think about an electric monopole
an electric monopole is just say an
electron it's just
a source of the electric field that has
one sign electrons have negative charge
protons have positive charge in
isolation each of them is a source of an
electromagnetic field that
radially spreads outward from
the location of the particle the
electron or the proton or any other
charged
particle of matter a magnetic monopole
would be the analog of that it would be
say one particle
that say is just a north pole or another
particle that is just
a south pole giving rise to a magnetic
field that emanates from those particles
now you may note that you have never
seen
an isolated north pole of a magnet
when you're a kid or beyond if you still
like magnets
you found that when you buy them they
always come in pairs
there's a bar say that has a north pole
and a south pole there's a horseshoe
that has a north pole and a south pole
and you say well
okay that's just the way it came from
the store if i just want to the north
pole of that bar magnet
i'll just lop off the north pole and
throw away the south pole and then i'll
just be left
with a monopole a single pole and the
answer to that as you no doubt no
is that that doesn't work because when
you try to lop off
the north pole where you cut the magnet
a south pole appears so you now have a
smaller
piece of the magnet a smaller bar but it
still has the north pole as before but
now the new
end acquires a south pole
you're unable to cut up a bar magnet and
isolate a single pole the north pole or
the south pole by themselves
and so there's no evidence that's
actually representative of a fact that
there's no evidence that
magnetic monopoles actually exist in
nature
but the question from stephen brown is
is it possible and the answer is yes
it's possible
the mathematics of maxwell's equations
of electricity and magnetism
absolutely allow for the possibility of
magnetic poles magnetic monopoles
and in fact the equations
are more beautiful if you include
magnetic monopoles
there's a particular equation called the
divergence equation in principle i can
write down equations using the system we
have here but i'm not going to bother
and the divergence of the electric field
according to maxwell
is proportional to the density of the
electric charge the density if you will
of the electric mono charges
the divergence of the magnetic field
is usually written down as zero because
maxwell's equations assume
that there are none of these magnetic
monopoles but if they do exist
then the divergence of the magnetic
field
would be proportional to the density of
the magnetic monopoles just like the
divergence of the electric field is
proportional to the density of the
electric monopoles
and that would be a beautiful symmetry
between electricity and magnetism which
is
almost but not quite realized
in the
the versions of maxwell's equations that
we currently
hold to be true so nobody knows if
magnetic monopoles exist
there was a discovery or an announcement
on
valentine's day i believe it was 1982.
don't hold me to that date but you know
roughly
roughly 28 years ago there was an
announcement
by a group that they had found a
magnetic monopole
there's a big spike in the output from a
detector
that the group used
and they thought they had it but no one
has been able to reproduce that
discovery of a magnetic monopole and
therefore most people
today believe that that
was an erroneous announcement
that magnetic monopoles are not real
but are they possible an answer to
stephen's question
absolutely they are possible no evidence
yet
uh dominic asks how does string theory
seal the bond between general relativity
and quantum mechanics i don't understand
and look
uh that's a deep question and
there's a mathematical answer to that
question which is
the one i indicated earlier
when you quantize the motion of a
vibrating string within the resulting
equations you find
einstein's equations of gravity so right
there there's the unity the bond the
union the coming together
because in the motion of a vibrating
filament quantum mechanically there
is einstein's equations wow that's cool
i don't know if that gives you much
intuition though for
why string theory succeeds in unifying
quantum mechanics
and gravity where a theory without
string theory doesn't
succeed and i can give you some
intuition for that
so one of the reasons why
it's hard to quantize einstein's theory
of gravity is this
einstein describes space in terms of
warps and curves
in the fabric okay right you have the
sun it warps the earth you know
those are the familiar images that come
to mind when we think about einstein's
theory
quantum mechanics because of the
uncertainty principle always talks about
a certain amount of
uncertainty which translates into a
certain kind of
jittery behavior undulating behavior in
any physical system
now when that physical system is the
fabric of space
those jitters cause the fabric of space
to widely undulate
and on very short distances the
undulations in the fabric of space are
so spectacular according to the
mathematics
that einstein's vision of space as nice
gently curving geometry and gently
curving geometrical shapes
that image is shattered that image
breaks down
and so it's the undulations from quantum
uncertainty that runs
smack into the central
paradigm of general relativity that the
fabric of space is gently curving
how does string theory resolve
that tension well here's what it does
string theory says
you can't ever get smaller than the
smallest ingredient in your
theory strength base says it doesn't
make sense to talk about the fabric of
space over distances that are smaller
than the size of
a string and basically we choose
the size of a string to be sufficiently
large
that the jitters that arise at that
scale
while non-zero are not big enough
to shatter einstein's image of a
gently curving geometry the jitters get
bigger
the smaller you proceed into the micro
world
and we cut off the jitters by saying you
can't go smaller than the size of a
string
that's how we put gravity and quantum
mechanics together in strength here and
that's really
a fairly accurate description of the the
actual
mathematical story of how of how this
works
i hope that gives you some intuition for
how that works blue smoker notes that
you can't handle the truth
some people can't certainly
those like jack nicholson
had trouble articulating the truth
and thought that others couldn't handle
it i don't know who the jack nicholson
of
string theory would be we'd like to
think that we are
intrepid explorers willing to accept any
truth that might
present itself to us okay
that was a long waste of time
to an offhand remark that i found in the
youtube comments so let me now get back
to business here
arjun asks if the speed of light is
constant no matter what then how does a
prism work and my answer to you are john
is that
we're sometimes a little bit loose in
our language
when we talk about
the speed of light being constant
and not changing what we mean is the
speed of light
in empty space the speed of light
through a vacuum not the speed of light
through a material
substance we have long known that when
light transitions
from going through empty space and going
through a material object like a prism
in your particular case we've long known
that the speed of light does change and
we have
measured to fantastic accuracy the speed
of light not just through empty space
but the speed of light through a whole
variety of different substances
and you're right a prism works by virtue
of the fact that different wavelengths
of light
have different speeds in a prism in some
sense and that causes
the frequencies of white light the
various wavelengths to separate
and undergo different bending and that's
how we separate light into its component
colors
and that does rely upon the speed of
light not being constant
in a material medium
something we've known about for a long
time not all in contradiction with our
claim that the speed of light is
constant because what we mean by that is
the speed of light through empty space
so sometimes we're loose language but i
hope that
clarifies that confusion and yeah
snell's law and people are chiming in
with their own understanding
of how light and glass light and a
vacuum
works satyam asks what happens if the
cosmological constant value
changes right now will there be an
immediate effect
and it depends
on how dramatically the cosmological
constant were to change
you know if in this region of space that
we're in right now if the
if the value of the dark energy were to
suddenly
grow by many many orders of magnitude
then yeah the world would change the
world would radically change
it could it could change by such a large
factor that
material objects might not even be able
to hold together any longer the
repulsive push of
the repulsive gravity from a
cosmological constant might below
material objects apart
atoms might be ripped apart electrons
that we were talking about before
in answer to someone's question i can't
remember the name
any longer but the question about are
atoms mostly empty space
so you've got electrons going around the
nucleus if it's mostly empty space
if the dark energy or the cosmological
constant were to change
in that region of empty space and become
fantastically large
it could blow electrons away from the
nucleus it could rip
atoms apart so it all depends on the
scale of the change but yeah if the
scale of the change is large enough
then that is something that we would
feel that would be something that would
change reality
as we know it all right
we're getting toward the end of our
conversation here
but i'm willing to go another 15 or so
minutes
to cross the three-hour threshold which
we've only done once before
partly because the first hour was um
made so much easier by that conversation
with adam reese so i've only had to talk
non-stop for two hours that's always
nice
uh but um let me see if i can find some
good questions
that uh yeah they're scrolling by
so region asks can the future influence
the past
is that what the delayed quantum choice
experiment proves
some people say that region written ch
i don't think that's the case at all i'm
a pretty firm believer in causality
i'm a pretty firm believer in the past
influencing the future but the future
not influencing the past
in that kind of causal sense of signals
being
sent back in time but there are these
funny experiments and the delayed
quantum choice experiment
is is one of those where it seems as
though
a decision you make in the future
affects the past what's the quantum
delay choice experiment
well we all know about the double slit
experiment
where you can choose to measure the
substance that you are examining in a
manner that
highlights its particle-like qualities
or it's wave-like qualities and if you
highlight its particle-like qualities
then it behaves like a particle if you
highlight its wave-like
features then it behaves like a wave
that has interference pattern so you get
different results depending upon
what you do in the past the
delayed quantum choice allows you to
delay your choice
of which quality of the object you study
in the past
until apparently enough time has gone by
that the particle itself had to commit
to either being a particle in a wave
and then it seems as though what you do
in the future can change that commitment
can change the past and that's the
language that's often used but that's
not
what's happening so if you want the
detailed explanation
look at my book fabric of the cosmos i
believe it's chapter seven
but in a nutshell it's simply the case
that your future action
influences the experiment in a way that
looks
as though appears as though
you get the same result as if the
password changed but that's very
different from saying you change the
past
you change the experiment at a given
moment in the future
and you change experiment which
influences the results and it just so
happens that you influence the results
in a way
that looks like what it would have
looked like how you influence the past
but did you actually influence the past
no
i do not think that you did
okay um a name
in arabic that i don't know how to
pronounce says does a quark have an
effect on space-time fabric
and yeah a quark has energy
and what we really learned from albert
einstein excuse me for one second
what we learned from albert einstein is
that any energy at all
influences the space-time fabric so
a cork has very little mass very little
energy so it has very
little impact on the structure of the
space-time fabric but it does and
i'm influencing the space-time fabric
right now
but i'm not influencing it very much
that's why
this camera and this monitor they're not
falling toward me the way they fall
toward planet earth planet earth
influences the space-time fabric in a
far more dramatic way
it has more mass the impact on the
space-time curvature is greater i have
little mass
and my impact on the space-time
curvature is less but i am
influencing i am impacting the
space-time curvature no doubt
about it that is what einstein teaches
us
so similar question to the one before
about the electromagnetic
field rom asks is light everywhere in
empty space
and then the second question that rahm
asks is what are the odds that professor
green will answer
my question huh well i haven't actually
answered your question yet so
i don't think people can calculate those
odds but i
am about to so is light everywhere in
empty space in a sense yes
depends exactly what you mean by light
all you know in everyday usage light
refers to very specific
vibrations of the electromagnetic field
that
our eyes because of evolutionary
pressures of having
evolved in an environment that has a sun
our eyes are well attuned to responding
to the wavelengths that the sun emits
our way our eyes are not well attuned to
see x-rays
or infrared rays or gamma rays
right those are a form of light
but our eyes aren't particularly good at
seeing those wavelengths
but if by light you mean the general
property of an undulating
electromagnetic field regardless of
which
frequencies those undulations are
undulating at
then in a sense light is everywhere
because
the electromagnetic field extends
everywhere there are places where its
value
may be incredibly close to zero so close
to zero that
it's as if it were not there but a
zero field is still a field
and that's a quantum mechanical notion
because the zero field
will still fluctuate about zero from the
quantum mechanical processes of quantum
mechanical uncertainty
in a classical world if a field has zero
value
there's nothing that commits you to
saying that the field is there the
difference between a field having value
zero
and being absent there's no
observational consequence so
it's really a matter of choice
but in quantum mechanics there is a
difference between a field having zero
value
and a field not existing because a field
that doesn't exist can't quantum
fluctuate
a field that does exist and has zero
value can still fluctuate
about that zero value and that's the
picture that quantum mechanics takes us
to
so in that quantum mechanical sense the
electromagnetic field
aka light does exist
everywhere hope that addresses the
question
okay so danny bittman is 25 too old to
go back to school to study physics and
no
although you have to really be realistic
about what your goals are maybe you are
the next einstein danny
and all you need to do is unlock your
inner physicist
and all wonder of spectacular result
will follow that's possible
of course it's unlikely it's unlikely
that any person is an albert einstein
i'm not an albert einstein you heard
nobel laureate adam reese in the first
hour
who won the nobel prize at 41 years old
said that he's no einstein so so
look you have to manage your own goals
and expectations
but if your goal instead is just to
deeply understand
the workings of nature understand the
fundamental equations
that guide the universe if you
perhaps want to contribute whatever you
can contribute
maybe getting a job maybe not getting a
job which is another thing to bear in
mind if you're willing to sort
of take all those those risks and still
find it worthwhile at the end of this
journey if you don't get a job
and all you do is commune with the
universe at a deeper level because you
understand its inner workings you
understand the equations of einstein and
schrodinger
and find men if you if that's enough
then i would say go for it
but you know people still need to eat
and if you're not independently wealthy
danny i'm not sure you know
oftentimes when you get a degree in
physics you are very marketable to other
fields unfortunately i can rattle off
a number of names of my phd students who
got the phd
and now work in wall street
or work in some kind of
hedge fund stock investment capacity
i get it you gotta eat and it's hard to
get a job
in the academic world not impossible but
the point is
if you hunger for that connection to the
mathematical underpinnings of the world
if you
hunger for that connection to the
physical processes that you can study as
an experimentalist
then yeah 25 is not not too old
to achieve that again if you're einstein
like i said you can achieve anything
even if you start late but if you're a
mere mortal like most of us it's hard
to get a job and it's hard
to succeed in that academic world sense
but that should not put you off if you
hunger for it sufficiently so samir
knows that even einstein worked at the
patent office and that that's true too
that's a little bit different einstein
didn't start late
einstein followed the usual trajectory
went to school i mean he missed a little
bit of school for a period of time
but he was not particularly old when
he got his degree in physics
he did kind of irritate some of the
faculty members
because he had no patience for people
who weren't as smart as he was
and that irritation led those
faculty members to not work very hard to
get einstein a job
in the academic world and so it was
einstein's
boyhood friend well school friend really
marcel grossman
whose father
gets einstein a job at the patent office
so yeah even einstein spent time out of
the academic world
all right so we got about five minutes
more
if uh if you still want to
hang out here um
what other questions uh roadrunner says
you aren't a mere
mortal i don't know who roadrunner's
referring to but if it's me
i can assure you i'm a mere mortal in
in in every category that that you might
imagine and the mere thought of that not
being the case
is causing my wife who may be listening
to this in one ear as she listens to a
podcast in the other
to roll her eyes to roll her eyes
no doubt um
let's see uh actually i haven't gone to
the uh
the youtube list in a while let me just
see if there's
anything there that i prop should have
uh answered
um loop quantum gravity from youtube
asks
are gravitational waves useful in
detecting extra dimensions
and also strings and and it may be
it may be you know because as as
gravitational waves propagate through
space
they're causing space to ripple that's
what a gravitational wave is and if
there are more dimensions of space in
the three that we know about
those extra dimensions in principle can
affect the precise details of the
rippling
perhaps even affect the speed of the
ripples or perhaps
even might cause ripples of different
frequencies
ripples are different wavelengths to
travel through
the higher dimensional spatial expanse
at different speeds
so it is conceivable that gravitational
waves may give us
give us insight into nature of string
theory and extra dimensions
nothing that i've seen yet that really
brings that idea home in a convincing
way
in an observational way but yeah
that is a real interesting possibility
for how gravitational waves and their
discovery
just a few years ago may play a vital
role in understanding
the next chapter of fundamental physics
okay what else i'm going to do another
youtube one for a second
uh mv asks on youtube could
or maybe this is the world science no
it's from the world science festival
page i'm sorry that wasn't youtube at
all i got it wrong
this is from the world science festival
page as opposed to the youtube page
because you can be watching the stream
i think you watch on youtube as many of
you are as like i said 774 of you are
right now
but you can also watch this on the world
science festival page or the world
science you
page as far as i know i think it's all
the same but they're different
communities in these different places so
you know if you want to hang out with
one group or another feel free to do it
okay
so mv asks on the world science festival
page
could dark matter be the cause of
repulsive gravity
and the answer to that question is no as
far as we know no
because here's the deal particles
that clump together into larger
collections of particles
clumpy things like particles give rise
to the usual attractive gravity
it's only when the energy is completely
uniformly spread out through a region of
space
that einstein's equations show that
repulsive gravity can emerge
and so particulate matter
which is the quintessential kind of
clumpy stuff is exactly the wrong
source for repulsive gravity
it's only the spread out energy field
that dark energy is a linguistic
summary of that's what we mean by dark
energy it's just energy that's uniformly
spread out and we don't see it
dark we don't see it energy is just
another word for uniformly distributed
it's a uniformly spread out energy
that gives rise to repulsive gravity
that that is the key quality that gives
it there
all right maybe one or two more
questions before
we wrap it up um
trevor iron wolf says only 800 viewers
for the green man yikes most of the
world must be asleep yeah i don't know
only 800 viewers oh you know i like
talking to you guys so
even though it's irrelevant even though
we're a small tight-knit community
of now 782 people it's uh it's good to
talk about yeah over time
i notice that over time people watch
these live streams i'm surprised i
thought that
people would only really want to watch
them in real time like we're doing right
here but people
enjoy watching them after the fact i
think some of the sessions that we had
some of the questions that you asked
some of the sessions have well over a
hundred thousand views in a few weeks so
that's fun
you know spreading the word somebody
asked how do you spread the word of
of science and that this is this is one
of the ways of doing that of course
um harveer asked did you ever make any
did you
ever have any collaborations with
mathematicians
when you're involved in string theory
and absolutely so
one of my most proud moments my most
proud discoveries was a discovery a
while back
where we showed that the fabric of space
can rip apart
topology change or the more precise
kind of topology change it was called a
flop transition
flop is not like the word the work was a
flop
it's a it's a mathematical term for
what can happen to a certain kind of
two-dimensional sphere embedded in a
higher dimensional space i won't go into
the details of it but
the way this result the way this
discovery came about was i was at the
institute for advanced study in
princeton
and i was sharing an office with
somebody that i knew a mathematician
named david morrison
and dave morrison and i he's a
mathematician i was a physicist we
decided to lecture to each other every
day
every evening actually so every evening
i'd give him a lecture on physic and
he'd give me an evening on
electron mathematics and we need to go
back to our our separate rooms and study
what we learned
from our mentor in the other field
and little by little through this
mentorship
we recognize that we could combine our
expertise together with
another mathematical physicist named
paul
aspinwall who's now at duke david
morrison's at ucsb we were able to
combine our
understanding from the math and the
physics to
prove that within string theory the
fabric of space could rip
and this result would not have emerged
if it wasn't
for this collaboration
between someone who was deeply
embedded in the world of math with paul
asmo
and myself who are deeply embedded in
the world of
physics so yes exactly right
all right so we've we've passed i think
the um
the three hour mark so i'm gonna
wrap it up with that a couple quick
things before we end again
as i mentioned let us know if you
enjoyed
the first hour conversation bringing in
a well-known person from the world of
physics or mathematics or some other
field as we go forward
usually someone who's done a world
science you master class so go to world
science u and
and check out the master class of adam
reese he did a wonderful job
giving a more detailed explanation of
the things we spoke about
in the first hour and i think that we'll
often do that going forward
have a guest not every week that we have
a
your daily equation or whatever we're
going to call these sessions going
forward
but oftentimes i think we're going to
shoot to do that it's kind of fun
also let me know what time you'd like us
to meet as i mentioned early on
this time slot fridays from whatever
three to six eastern daylight or eastern
standard whatever the heck time we're on
right now
isn't going to work well for me after
september i have to teach my course at
columbia
if you guys want to take my course at
columbia i don't think columbia would
allow that though
uh but that course meets from 2 p.m to 5
p.m
uh on friday so i got to choose a
different time slot on friday
make a recommendation or a suggestion or
a different day maybe thursdays from two
to five whatever
and you know if there's a dominant time
slot that happens to emerge
in the comments section i'll certainly
take that into account
otherwise again thanks for hanging out
for the last three hours those of you
who have been here the whole time
those of you who have not you can watch
the recording of this as we post it
and uh and i'm not sure exactly when the
next live session will be maybe next
friday or the friday after
but until then take care this is brian
green
signing off thanks
you